Hallo, hier ist Chaosradio Express Ausgabe Nummer 142. Es dauert immer länger, die Sendungszahl hier anzusagen. Das ist ein gutes Zeichen. Es geht voran hier bei Chaosradio Express. Und mein Name ist wie immer Tim Pritlove. Ich begrüße euch an euren Endgeräten. Und ja, will heute mal wieder ein Thema auf den Tisch legen, was vielleicht ein bisschen unerwartet kommt. Das sind mir immer die Liebsten. Und ihr hört schon, zu Gast ist mal wieder jemand. Und zwar im Konkreten und Besonderen ist es Kai Kobschätzki. Hallo. Und wir wollen heute mal über was ganz Spannendes reden, was ja überhaupt der Hit ist in allen Clubs. Und worüber jeder immer gerne redet. Nicht wahr? Über Steuern.
Ja, das wird sicherlich das erste Thema, das wir hier immer selber auf jedem Stamm tun.
Geht dir das auch so, dass es nicht auf jeder Party in der Küche, wenn die Leute sagen, du hast was mit Steuern zu tun, kannst du über Steuern reden?
Ja, das kommt natürlich schon gerne mal. Sagen wir mal, wie man die großen Steuern spart. Und ich hab da auch noch was. Und müsste ich dringend mal machen. Also natürlich wird man darauf angesprochen.
Aber jetzt immer nur mehr mit, ich hab da ein Problem und ich verstehe das nicht, als dass man jetzt wirklich mal in so eine fetzige Diskussion über Steuern kommt, wie man in Irak diskutiert oder so.
Also das kommt, finde ich, erstaunlicherweise weitaus weniger. Wobei ich da genug Potenzial vergebe. Man merkt aber so, dass gerade vor Wahlen das Bedürfnis eher höher wird und danach sinkt.
Verstehe. Erstaunlicherweise. Du findest das erstaunlich, dass die Leute da nicht drauf abfahren, weil es doch so geil ist.
Naja, ich finde es deshalb erstaunlich, weil es betrifft einfach jeden. Also man geht halt in den Laden und bezahlt was und zahlt automatisch Umsatzsteuer.
Aber es steuert nicht so ein bisschen was wie AIDS. Das betrifft eigentlich auch jeden, aber da will auch keiner drüber reden.
Aber es macht sich hoffentlich jeder Gedanken drüber.
Ich glaube, im stillen Kämmerlein glaube ich halt schon, dass die Leute sich darüber Gedanken machen. Bloß ist es halt einfach so etwas, was einem dann auch ganz schnell Bauchschmerzen bereitet. Und du weißt ja, wie das ist. Man blendet dann ja auch schnell aus und sagt irgendwie, wenn ich jetzt ganz lange nicht darüber nachdenke, dann geht das wahrscheinlich von alleine weg. Das sind doch dann die Leute, die dann... Das ist bei Ärzten auch nicht so. Ja, das ist bei Steuern auch nicht so. Ich schätze mal, die dürften dann vor Jahresende bei dir dann auch immer gehäuft auftreten, dann diese Leute, die gesagt haben, jetzt habe ich zwei Wochen lang versucht, das wegzudenken, aber es ist trotzdem noch da.
Ja, und es verschwindet einfach nicht. Aber es gibt auch erstaunlicherweise, man sagt, sie zahlen sie grundsätzlich gerne, weil sie es einsehen.
Naja, ich glaube, gerade in Nerdkreisen geht es ja gar nicht so sehr darum, dass man nicht steuernd zahlen möchte. Man möchte bloß nicht an der Berechnung oder vor allem an dieser Zettelsammlung beteiligt werden, weil das ist glaube ich der eigentliche Vorgang, der vielen Leuten Angst macht. Gar nicht so sehr diese Vergegenwärtigung, weil man weiß ja irgendwie auch, wenn man es nicht macht, zahlt man sowieso noch mehr. Und ich glaube, viele Leute werden auch glücklich, wenn sie einfach nur jedes Jahr einfach eine Strafe zahlen, die einen festen Beitrag hat. Nur, damit sie halt nicht mit diesem ganzen Zettelwald machen müssen. Also das ist definitiv etwas, was ich aus eigener Erfahrung auch kenne. Und ich vermute mal und weiß auch, dass das gerade so in computeraffinen Kreisen auch nochmal besonders verbreitet ist.
Ist halt auch viel analog, mit dem man das zu kämpfen hat.
Genau. Jetzt muss man natürlich erst nochmal ein bisschen ausholen und auch nochmal sagen, was du machst, hast ja schon durchklingen lassen. Du hast da irgendwie mit zu tun. Bist aber jetzt nicht im einigen Sinne ein Steuerberater?
Ich bin Rechtsanwalt und mache als Rechtsanwalt eigentlich überwiegend einen Teil das, was man sich unter einem klassischen Steuerberater vorstellt. Also auch Steuererklärungen erstellen, Jahresabschlüsse machen und so die Gestaltungsberatung drum herum. Also das ist, wissen zwar viele nicht, aber Rechtsanwälte sind zu unbeschränkten Rechtsberatungen gefugt und dazu zählt auch Steuerrecht.
Wenn man sich da auskennt. Andere Leute haben andere Spezialisierungen. Bei dir ist es eben das. Ja, das hat mich dazu gebracht, doch mal das Thema Steuern dann auch mal hier auf den Tisch zu heben, weil ich finde das an sich doch sehr interessant. Und wollte ich ja mal versuchen, ein wenig dem Wiesen der Steuern dann auch näher zu kommen. Also wer sich jetzt hier eine konkrete Steuerberatung gewünscht hat, der ist natürlich falsch. Da hätten wir die Zahlen auch vor dem Beginn der Sendung bekommen müssen. Das funktioniert natürlich hier aus grundsätzlichen Konzeptgründen nicht. Ja, du hast auch einen Vortrag gehalten, das sollte man vielleicht zu Beginn auch gleich nochmal erwähnen. Jetzt auf dem letzten Chaos-Communication-Kongress. Da ging es jetzt weniger um Steuern im Allgemeinen als vielmehr um die Digitalisierung des Steuersystems im Besonderen.
Auf dem Kongress ging es jetzt nicht darum, was Steuern sind und so. Das habe ich zwar am Anfang auch mal kurz erläutert, aber es ging primär um zwei Themenkomplexe. Mein Kollege Peter Keune, der eine Kanzlei in Dortmund betreibt, hat sich um die digitale Betriebsprüfung gekümmert. Dort geht es um die Frage, wie kann man sehr große Zahlenmengen statistisch verarbeiten, was durch den Einsatz von Rechnern ganz neue Dimensionen gewonnen hat. Mein Teil ging um die Frage, was sammelt das Finanzamt und was sammelt Dritte im Auftrag des Finanzamtes oder andere Behörden, wo das Finanzamt eben mit abzapfen darf, an Daten so an. Was sammeln die, wer kriegt welche Daten, wo fliegen die überall durch die Gegend?
Da werden wir sicherlich auch nochmal an das Thema anstoßen. Aber ich denke gerade, um solche Themenkomplexe zu verstehen, wie aber auch die generelle politische Diskussion, die ja eigentlich permanent ist. Man vergeht ja keinen Tag, wo man nicht vielleicht das Radio einschaltet und so die aktuellen Nachrichtendiskussionen hat und den Ausschnitten der politischen Diskussion. Und immer geht es darum, die eine Steuer doch vielleicht in die eine Richtung und die andere Steuer in die andere Richtung zu schieben. Aber keiner weiß eigentlich jemals, ob das nun eine gute Idee ist und was das bewirkt oder so.
Ich glaube, dass viel Unfug, der dann der Politik auch diskutiert wird, wo man sich eigentlich ein bisschen mit der Materie beschäftigt und am Kopf fassen kann, gerade deshalb so gepostet werden kann, weil man fest davon ausgeht, die meisten Bürger werden schon keine Ahnung haben und man dort eine Menge Blödsinn auch in die Welt setzen kann.
Wäre es so ein bisschen so, als würde man im Radio über Colonel Traber Development reden und eine öffentliche Diskussion darüber ausheben, ob man nun irgendwie ein messagebasiertes Interface oder dann doch vielleicht ein Darien-Call-Interface machen sollte?
Ich glaube, das werden die meisten Zuhörer nachvollziehen können, weil es jetzt genau das ist, wie es um diese ganze Internetpolitik sich handelt. Viel, was jemand wie Zensurursel macht, funktioniert eben nur, weil die meisten nicht wissen, worum es geht. Das ist bei Steuern auch nicht viel anders.
Gut, dann steigen wir doch da mal ein. Worum geht es denn eigentlich? Was soll denn der ganze Mist? Wo kommt denn das her, wer hat denn das verbrochen, wer hat uns das denn angehängt?
Also Steuern selbst sind uralt, weil mit Steuern...
Gibt es da wirklich wissenschaftliche Erkenntnisse, wie alt?
Ja, gibt es. Ich meine, gelesen zu haben Assyria oder so die ersten. Also es ist wirklich alt. Also es ist überhaupt nichts Neues. Denn es war schon immer so, dass das Gemeinwesen durch Steuern finanziert werden musste oder finanziert wurde.
Also es setzt natürlich erstmal das Ausbilden eines Gemeinwesens voraus. Das hatte man dann irgendwann so. Und ja, dann gab es immer Leute, die sich sozusagen mehr ums Gemeinwesen kümmern als andere. Und die brauchen dafür Mittel.
Die brauchen dafür Mittel. Und man hat halt unterschiedliche Möglichkeiten.
Gab es da auch schon Geld? Also reden wir jetzt schon von Steuern in Form von Geld? Oder reden wir in Form von Steuern im Sinne von gib mir was von deiner Ernte ab?
Also das ist die moderne Definition, die wir heute auch im Gesetz stehen haben, die setzt Geldleistung voraus. Aber das war natürlich nicht immer so. Das gibt zwei Zeiten, so was wie Kirchenzent, wo wir das früher schon über Geld geregelt hatten. Aber genau das, was du ansprichst, sowas wie frohen Arbeiten, das ist im Strengen genommen nichts anderes als eine Besteuerung, nur der Arbeitsleistung. Also ich sage, entweder du musst bei mir aus dem Feld gehen, du musst arbeiten, oder gib mir ein Teil von deiner Ernte ab. Das ist sicherlich einer Modernisierung der Volkswirtschaft und der Geldwirtschaft geschuldet, dass wir darauf verzichten können, weil das unpraktikabel ist. Also man stelle sich vor, man müsste sich einmal im Monat für eine Stunde beim Finanzamt melden und sagen, ich bin jetzt hier zum Arbeiten.
Ich dachte, mit Hartz IV haben wir das jetzt auch wieder eingeführt.
Ja, aber das beträgt dann ja auch nur einen Teil. Und die zahlen ja gerade keine Steuern. Also der Hartz IV bekommt, zahlt keine Steuern. Also Umsatzsteuer aber keine einzigen Steuern.
Man muss natürlich nochmal voranstellen, du kennst dich mit dem deutschen Recht aus, das lässt dich jetzt nicht so ohne weiteres auf, wir haben ja auch noch viele Hörer in Österreich, in der Schweiz, keine Ahnung, wie du das so wahrnimmst, wie groß die Ähnlichkeiten und die Unterschiede sind. Sicherlich im Detail sehr vielfältig.
Ja, die sind, also da bewegen wir uns im Kreis, der unserem noch sehr ähnlich ist, gerade auch mit Österreich, weil es eben in der Europäischen Union liegt. Aber das ist Ausland und da halte ich mich als deutscher Jurist ganz stark zurück, wenn mich da nicht am Fenster lehnen. Natürlich hat man immer wieder Berührungspunkte, auch mit den Vereinigten Staaten, auch da hat man Berührungspunkte, aber das ist...
Das ist was anderes. Wir sind ja jetzt erst mal ein bisschen in dieser Geschichte. Also frohen Arbeit, klar, der Zehnt und so. Also wo... Aber wie war das? Gab es da dann schon verschiedene Arten von Steuern? Oder gab es einfach nur die Steuer?
Na ja, das wurde ja nicht in der fein zisillierten Art festgesetzt, wie wir das haben. Also, dass wir wirklich Steuergesetzgebung haben, wie wir sie heute kennen, das ist ja eher ein moderneres Phänomen, was wir schon bei den Römern hatten.
Also gab es keine Turmbrücken, Zugketten, Ausbau, Zuschusssteuer oder so?
Na ja, das Gemeinwesen wurde im Mittelalter zu einem nicht unerheblichen Teil anders finanziert. Das fand eben mehr direkte Erhebung statt, also gerade was du ansprichst, wie eine Brücke. Die Brücke wurde eben dann vielfach über einen Zoll, den man entrichten musste, wenn man drüber gegangen ist.
Ah, Maut.
Oder Maut, ja. Kommt ja auch wieder. Was wir heute nicht haben, oder eben Schulen, die dann über Schulgeld finanziert wurden, also wo vielen mehr an den jeweiligen Punkten finanziert wurde, während es heute so ist, dass wir massiv viel, was wir vielleicht auch gar nicht so richtig wahrnehmen, aus einem allgemeinen Pod finanziert wird, den wir über Steuern finanzieren.
Aber so auch so diese Hofstaaten und Bogen und so weiter, ich meine, da würden ja auch viele Ausgaben gemacht, so aus der vollen, das muss ja dann auch erstmal in Vermögen entnommen worden sein. Ist das dann nicht auch so, dass zu diesem Vermögen alle gleichem Maße zutrugen?
Ich bin jetzt kein Historiker, aber ich glaube nicht, dass die bei den Bauern da wirklich angefangen haben, zu sagen, ihr müsst jetzt 4,9% eures Vermögens abgeben, sondern dass da eher gegangen wurde, du kommst jetzt mal arbeiten.
Aber wie hat sich das denn dann so entwickelt? Ich meine, wenn du sagst, okay, heute haben wir da moderne Konzepte, la la la, wann haben die sich denn so herausgebildet?
Also so richtig hat sich das, was wir heute haben, in Preußen herausgebildet. Das ist unser jetziges Einkommensteuerrecht, das preußisches Einkommensteuerrecht, was wir zwar modernisiert haben natürlich, da gibt es ja dauernd Änderungen, aber die Grundkommission, das ist die Miguelische Steuerreform aus Preußen, also grob 18. Jahrhundert.
Also wir senden hier sozusagen gerade direkt aus dem EP-Zentrum der Steuergeschichte.
Ja, durchaus, durchaus, ja. Aber wir haben, wenn wir jetzt nochmal kurz bei der Geschichte, weil das finde ich immer ganz witzig, es ist, dass die Diskussion, wie die ja jeder kennen, so gleicher Steuersatz, Steuerprogression, das ist ja etwas, was die Liberalen noch immer wieder nach vorne bringen. Das ist ein Teil, der ist biblisch. Also Kirchen 10 ist sicherlich auch ein Begriff. Da heißt es halt, wir machen fix 10%. Da gibt es eine Geschichte aus dem 9. Testament, wie Jesus gesagt hat. Aber Moment mal, wenn jemand arm ist und eine kleine Geldmünze nur reinwirft, ist das aber im Verhältnis gesehen viel mehr, als wenn ein Reicher eine große Geldmünze reinwirft. Weil für ihn ist das fast nichts. Und das sind Diskussionen, die wir ja bis heute vortragen. Also man sieht, die Grunddiskussionen, die sind nicht wirklich neu. Machen wir einen festen Tarif, so wie bei der Umsatzsteuer, 19% und das war's. Oder sagen wir, wir machen einen variablen Tarif über der Einkommenssteuer, wo man sagt, man fängt eben mit 14% an und steigt dann hoch. Und das sind also Sachen, die schon alzen und ihre Geschichte haben und sich fortgetragen haben und die wir durch unterschiedliche Steuerkonzepte, wie beispielsweise Umsatzsteuer und Einkommenssteuer, unterschiedlich auch in das Volk bringen.
Inwiefern äußert sich da dieses Bibeldokument zu der Steuerproblematik im Besonderen? War das jetzt nur so Jesus-Sätze, die er da so gesagt hat? Oder gibt es da irgendwie auch noch so ein Buch der Steuern?
Nee, so nicht. Aber wenn man dieses Gleichnis von Jesus nimmt, dann muss man sagen, man braucht eine Steuerprogression. Also das wäre die Folgerung daraus.
Okay. Ja, den Kirchen zähnt. Den Begriff hat sicherlich jeder schon mal gehört. Das nahm so irgendwie 10% als das Steuerideal an, oder wie?
Ja, man sollte 10% des Einkommens abgeben. Das kennen wir oft von anderen Religionen. Dass man so dieser Größenordnung etwas abgeben soll, um die Kirche als einen besonderen Teil des Gemeinwesens zu finanzieren.
Da ging es aber nur um die Kirche. Es kann durchaus noch sein, dass noch andere Leute gekommen sind, die auch noch einen Zehnt haben wollen.
Es geht nur um den besonderen Teil der Kirche, um diesen Teil des Gemeinwesens zu finanzieren. In Deutschland haben wir das mit der Kirchenbesteuerung, wobei es dort viel, viel weniger ist als 10%, haben wir das ja auch noch. Das sind 8-9% der Einkommenssteuer, die man da abführt. Man nähert sich dem Zehnt an, aber lange nicht dem wirklichen Zehnt, weil dann müsste uns das Einkommen gehen. Wir nehmen etwas von der Einkommenssteuer, das ist relativ wenig, auch wenn man sich das anders sieht. Aber es ist relativ wenig im Vergleich zu dem, was man geben müsste. Das ist genau das selbe Prinzip, diejenigen, die zu dieser Gemeinschaft gehören. Dazu zählt auch die israelische Kultussteuer. Also Juden dürfen beispielsweise Kirchensteuern erheben. Das heißt zwar nicht Kirchensteuer, aber das System ist dasselbe. Um eben diese Religionsgemeinschaften zu finanzieren. Und das ist etwas, was ein gegenseitiges Übereinkommen ist. Der Staat treibt das Geld für die Gemeinde, also für die Kirchen ein. Lässt sich das aber auch bezahlen. Also das ist jetzt nicht nur ein Gutwill, sondern man nutzt dort das Inkasso des Staates und bezahlt dafür.
So und jetzt in Preußen, sagst du, da hat sich was gewandelt. Was hat sich denn da so ergeben?
Man hat das System der Besteuerung, wie wir es heute haben, dass wir Einkunftsarten haben, dass wir ein geregeltes Ablaufverfahren haben. Also dass wir sagen, wir haben ein Ermittlungsverfahren, wir haben ein Erhebungsverfahren, wir haben ein Beitreibungsverfahren. Diese ganzen Verfahrensgrundsätze, die haben sich in Preußen manifestiert in einer Form, wie wir sie heute noch in den Steuergesetzen haben. Also wie vieles an Rauch, was wir aus Preußen haben, hat sich auch das bis heute erhalten.
Was für Verfahren meinst du jetzt konkret so?
Beispielsweise die Reichsabgabenordnung, die wurde zwar 77 als Abgabenordnung unbenannt, aber da sind die meisten Verfahrensgrundsätze und wie überhaupt so dieses Besteuerungsverfahren funktioniert. Ich muss erstmal ermitteln, den steuerlichen Sachverhalt, ich muss dann irgendwann mal die Steuer festsetzen und danach muss ich die Steuer beitreiben. Das sind so grundlegende Verfahren, die wir von seiner Zeit haben. Und wo man sagen muss, es waren sich Feinheiten geändert, aber so das Grundkonstrukt ist eigentlich dasselbe geblieben.
Also es geht jetzt weniger um sozusagen wie die Steuern so sind, sondern es ging eigentlich mehr so um das Verfahren, das bürokratische, staatliche Verfahren des Eintreibens dieser Steuern.
Ja.
Erhebens natürlich auch.
Und auf der anderen Seite auch bei den Steuern selbst, also die Einkommenssteuer, wo man sagt, man nimmt sich ein Steuerobjekt, also das Einkommen, man nimmt sich das Steuersebjekt, also diese Betrachtungsweise, den Menschen und fängt dort an zu sagen, okay, wir besteuern bei dir folgende Einkünfte, erstens, zweitens, drittens, und setzen darauf dann einen Steuersatz fest, der sich nach deiner Höhe richtet. Das ist etwas, was wir auch schon von den Preußen haben. Und das hat sich im Grundsatz erstmal nicht wirklich geändert. Also trotz aller Änderungen, die wir dauernd haben, aber so dieses Grundprinzip, das ist gleichgeblieben.
Waren dann die Preußen, sagen wir jetzt, auch international vorne, oder?
Das gibt es auch andere.
Ich meine, man würde es fast vermuten wollen, so, nicht?
Ja, muss ich sagen, da muss ich passen. Also ich habe mir da zu der Zeit nie vergleichende Studien geschwangen.
Wenn das einen internationalen Vergleich raus ist, haben wir ja im Prinzip am Anfang auch schon den Disclaimer schon abgeliefert. Bleiben wir also bei den Preußen. Ich hoffe, die bayerischen Hörer bleiben uns jetzt auch noch erhalten.
Na jetzt haben sie ja das Preußische gut auch inhaliert.
Ja, jetzt überlege ich gerade, wie man sich dem eigentlich jetzt am besten nähern kann. Ich denke, was es erstmal zu verstehen gilt, ist, was für Arten von Steuern überhaupt so erhoben werden. Und was mich besonders immer interessiert, ist auch immer so dieses Warum eigentlich? Also man muss ja auch bei jeder Steuer irgendwann mal so ein, wie soll ich sagen, so ein mentales Grundgerüst dahinter haben, dass man sagt, das ist jetzt aber auch wirklich ein Ansatz, der in irgendeiner Form die Einforderungen auch legitimiert und im besten Fall natürlich auch nachvollziehbar.
Also das müsste man vielleicht so nach zwei Teilen unterschauen. Das eine ist bei dem Warum, fange ich mir den kleineren Teil an, das sind sogenannte Lenkungsnormen, also wo ich durch Steuern versuche, ein bestimmtes Verhalten zu erzeugen. Ein Beispiel, das sofort jedem auf der Zunge liegen müsste, ist Tabaksteuer. Also ich sage, ich besteuere das höher als andere Verbrauchsgüter mit dem Sinn und Spektrum, die Leute sollen weniger rauchen. Und der Hauptgrund ist völlig klar, die Finanzierung des Gemeinwesens. Also in allererste Linie, und das schließt den Lenkungssteuern nicht aus, sehen wir bei der Tabaksteuer, das bringt auch ordentlich Geld im Staat, aber das vordergründigste Ziel der Steuer ist die Finanzierung des Gemeinwesens, die Straßen, auf denen wir laufen, die Schulen, die Universitäten und Krankenhäuser, was alles dranhängt, muss irgendwie finanziert werden, auch die Gehälter der Bundestagsabgeordneten, und das wird eben alles aus dem großen Steuertopf finanziert. Das steht überall. Und dann kann man sich die Frage stellen, bei wem und warum ziehe ich ausgerechnet etwas Bestimmtes aus der Tasche? Und da gibt es verschiedene Konzepte, das sind einmal die sogenannten Besitzsteuern, dort ist die Rechtfertigung, da bekommt jemand was. Die sogenannten Ertragssteuern, also das ist so was wie Einkommensteuern, Körperschaftssteuer, Gewerbesteuer.
Also geht es da ums Bekommen oder ums Haben?
Ums Bekommen, also der Begriff Besitzsteuer ist ein Oberbegriff, einmal für die sogenannten Ertragssteuern. Und daneben gibt es die sogenannten Substanzsteuern. Und die Substanzsteuern, das ist der Bereich Grundsteuern, Vermögensteuer, wobei wir die Vermögensteuer zurzeit nicht haben. Und die Ertragssteuern, das ist eben so diese, wie gesagt, Einkommenssteuer. Das ist das, was wohl jeden betreffen dürfte. Körperschaftssteuer, das ist dann das für die GmbH, das sind die Gewerbesteuer für die Gewerbentreibenden. Und da sage ich bei diesen Ertragssteuern für die Tatsache, dass ich etwas bekomme, muss ich auch Steuern zahlen.
Jetzt noch mal ganz langsam mit den Pferden. Also du hast jetzt im Prinzip, wir reden jetzt von so einer Art Top-Level-Kategorie. Wie teilt sich das alles auf? Dann hatten wir jetzt Besitzsteuern.
Das ist so ein Oberbegriff.
Ja, also das ist eine Top-Level-Kategorie sozusagen. Dann hast du erwähnt die Verbrauchsteuern, die sind davon separat.
Ja genau, also neben den Besitzsteuern gibt es diese Verbrauchsteuern und die Verkehrssteuern, das sind so die drei Top-Level, die ich habe.
Und diese Substanz, dann hast du noch Substanzsteuer gesagt. Das ist jetzt aber auch schon wieder ein Teil von den Besitzsteuern. Jetzt sollten wir erstmal bei einer Kategorie bleiben. Nämlich eben dieser, ich meine, es ist ja viel hinzugekommen. War denn jetzt in Preußen von vornherein all das sozusagen von vornherein vertreten oder kann man von irgendeiner Steuer sprechen, die eher die klassische Steuersteuer ist?
Also die klassische Steuer dürfte sich ja nicht die Grundsteuer sein, also wo ich wirklich an den Besitz rangehe. Wobei die Frage wie Grundsteuer, also das was wir ja heute immer noch haben, wo ich sage, ich habe ein bestimmtes Grundstück, davon muss ich Grundsteuer zahlen.
Also Grundsteuer bezieht sich nur auf Haus, Boden, Grund, Bodeneigentum. Jeder Quadratmeter, den man besitzt, auf den zahlt man Grundsteuer? Generell?
Ja, und das wird nach einem, brauchen wir das glaube ich besser nicht vertiefen, komplizierenden Verfahren berechnet, wie sich diese Grundsteuer dann berechnet. Da geht es um einen sogenannten Ertragswert. Also wie viel Geld könnte ich theoretisch aus diesem Grundstück rausziehen? So berechnen wir heute die Grundsteuer. Die zahlt im Übrigen aber trotzdem fast jeder, weil die für je die Miete umlegbar ist. Und dadurch, jeder, der Miete zahlt, zahlt im Regelfall indirekt auch die Grundsteuer seines Vermieters mit.
Was ist da sozusagen die Legitimation dahinter?
Was ist sozusagen... Man sagt bei den Grundstücken, ich habe die Möglichkeit, also das ist die Rechtfertigung, ich habe die Möglichkeit, aus einem Grundstück Geld zu machen. Und für diese Möglichkeit zahle ich Grundsteuern. Also man setzt gar nicht so richtig an den Besitz an, nur weil ich es habe, sondern weil ich die Möglichkeit habe, damit Geld zu machen. Das ist so die Rechtfertigung für diese Grundsteuer. Und die Grundsteuer selbst, also das ist eine alte Steuer. Die Frage ist nur, mit was gehe ich da ran? Also da gibt es verschiedene Ansätze, in denen ich sage, so ein Ertragswert, wie wir es jetzt haben. Aber es gab auch schon andere Ansätze. Man hat in Frankreich und in England, denn das kommt der Grundsteuer schon im Prinzip nahe, mal so eine genannte Fenstersteuer gehabt. Da hab ich gesagt, okay, ich guck mir an, wie viel Fenster jemand hat. Das lässt darauf schließen, wie viel wertvoll sein Gebäude ist. Und die haben dann wirklich einfach die Fenster durchgezählt und haben danach eine Steuer erhoben. Das hat übrigens auch in England, also ich glaube, das war 18. Jahrhundert, 17. bis 18. Jahrhundert, dann auch schon zu den ersten Folgen gehabt. Die haben das dann immer weiter angehoben, diese Fenstersteuer. Das hat dann dazu geführt, dass die Leute irgendwann angefangen haben, ihre Fenster zuzumauern.
Und immer wieder Fenster eingebaut haben und alle saßen im Dunkeln.
Jaja, also man hat dann gesagt, dann mauern wir die Dinge halt einfach zu. Also die Steuerflucht war dann halt die Dunkelheit. Also auch Steuerflucht ist kein neues Phänomen, wie man sieht.
Aber daran sieht man im Prinzip, es ist immer so dieser Kampf um die Deutung, was denn nun wirklich eigentlich das charakteristische Merkmal ist, um einen Geldvorteil, den irgendjemand hat, auch zu bewerten. Und bei der Grundsteuer kommt mir so ein bisschen vor, wie eigentlich so die klassische Eigentumssteuer schlechthin. Weil ich meine, wenn man jetzt ganz zurückdenkt, irgendwann gehörte ja mal nichts überhaupt irgendjemand. Sowieso ein sehr schwieriger Geburtsstatus. Also wie kam es eigentlich dazu, dass irgendwann mal jemandem was gehörte, weil es muss ihm ja irgendjemand dann gegeben haben. Und das konnte ja nicht sein, weil es gehört ja noch keinem. Also haben sich die Leute wahrscheinlich am Anfang irgendwann einfach erst mal genommen.
Wildwest-Panier?
Genau, so war es dann halt einfach. Ist meins, geh weg, sonst tue ich schlimme Dinge mit dir. Und irgendwann, ich fabuliere jetzt so ein bisschen, sag mal, ob das stimmt oder nicht. Und irgendwann war das sozusagen so, ok, alles klar, der Platz wird eng. Und es ist klar, dass Leute, die jetzt Platz haben, bevorteilt sind. Und für diesen Vorteil müssen sie sozusagen der Gesellschaft wieder etwas zurückführen. Kann man das so sagen?
Das kann man so sagen. Also ob das so mit dem Gesellschaft wieder zurückführen so durchdacht war, wage ich zu bezweifeln, sondern eher du hast viel, also kannst du auch was abgeben. Also ich glaube, dass man dann etwas schlichter gehandhabt. Aber dieses Prinzip der Gesellschaft zurückgeben, das haben wir eben bis heute.
Aber das ist im Prinzip so ein, du hast viel, ist sozusagen ja auch ein statisches Moment. Also du hast es schon und solange du es auch weiterhin hast, musst du mir dafür oder den anderen dafür immer wieder permanent was geben. Es ist nicht so, dass du es irgendwann mal abbezahlt hast, sondern diese Grundsteuer ist einfach immer da und die geht auch nicht weg.
Die geht nicht weg. Solange ich die Möglichkeit habe, aus diesem Grundstück Erträge zu erzielen, muss ich auch zahlen.
Und gibt es irgendwelche Grundstücke, die von so einer Grundsteuer ausgenommen sind?
Gibt es ja für, nicht das richtige Erinnerung habe, so gemeinnützige, die sind davon ausgenommen.
Dann hängt es davon ab, was sich auf diesem Grund befindet? Ist ein Quadratmeter Wasser genauso teuer wie ein Quadratmeter Land?
Nein, das richtet sich nach einem Bewertungsgesetz. Also wie ich den Wert eines solchen Grundstücks ermittle. Wie gesagt, da richtet sich danach, was kann ich an sich aus so einem Grund und Boden für einen Wert ziehen? Also einen fiktiven Wert, den ich daraus ziehen könnte. Da geht es dann mehr um solche Fragen, habe ich dort ein Einfamilienhaus drauf? Oder habe ich eine Leerfläche drauf? Habe ich eine Lagerhalle drauf und sowas?
Also auch der Bebauungszustand fließt quasi mit daheim?
Der fließt ein, aber es fließt halt sehr grob ein. Also das ist jetzt nicht so, das wird dort wirklich...
Was zahlt man denn so, üblicherweise? Also was ist denn so, nicht jetzt so ein Quadratkilometer Landbesäße? Was ich nicht tue? Das ist ja schon relativ viel. Oder womit bemisst man das Hektar wahrscheinlich? Das wäre so ein Maß anhalten, die keiner parat hat, wie viel das eigentlich wirklich ist.
Ja, käme dann darauf an, was du hast, wenn es so land- und forstwirtschaftlich betrieben ist. Ich habe das so richtig in Erinnerung bei so einem, was ich jetzt noch bei einer Mandantenmagazine habe, in der Abrechnung, da war so Wiesenfläche, die da wirklich mit irgendwelchen Schafen bevölkert werden. Und ich meine, die zahlen da irgendwie, was, 2-300 Euro im Jahr. Also das war nicht wirklich bewegend viel für solche Grundstücke in der Stadt. Mit mehr Familienhaus, da zahlste deutlich mehr. Aber das lässt sich schlecht auf einen Quadratmeter runterrechnen.
Wie viel hat der bezahlt?
Ich glaube, es waren 200-300 Euro. Pro? Für seinen, ich weiß nicht, was der mehr hat.
Ich meine, pro Jahr, oder was? Pro Jahr, pro Jahr. 200 Euro pro Jahr für einen Hektar.
Also man kann die Grundsteuer schlichtweg nicht auf einen Quadratmeter runterrechnen. Das funktioniert, dafür ist das...
Okay, das ist nur mal eine Größenordnung im Kopf zu haben. Es ist auch nicht, dass man da viele Tausende Euro für zahlen muss, aber so ein paar Hundert können schon fließen, wenn man irgendwie mal so...
Ja.
Weiß ich jetzt nicht genau, wie groß das war?
Ich glaube, es waren so anderthalb Hektar.
Also Hektar, 100 Meter mal 100 Meter. Ist ja ordentlich wenig.
Ja, also das ist halt etwas, was man dann in der Pacht einkalkulieren muss. Also ich kann den Zuhörer nur mal anraten, soll er sich einfach mal seine Betriebskostenabrechnung nehmen, dort wird er die Position Grundsteuer finden und dann sieht er, was er für seine Wohnung anteilig in Grundsteuern zahlt.
Also jetzt als Mieter meinst du?
Als Mieter, weil ich als Mieter die Grundsteuer des Vermieters anteilig mitbezahle. Und dort kann ich mir das dann mal anschauen, was das anfällt. Und das ist jetzt keine Größenordnung, die einen umbringt, aber es ist jetzt auch nicht so, dass es gar nichts ist.
Ist das so eine volatile Steuer? Ändert sich da viel an dieser Grundsteuer?
Nö, das ist eine relativ stabile Geschichte.
Weil hier in Berlin habe ich so gerade so ein Echo im Kopf, dass da mal über eine gerietfügige Anhebung nachgedacht wurde.
Ja, die wurde auch schon mal angehoben, aber das ist so eine Steuer, wo auch...
Sind das dann immer so die harten Zeiten, wenn irgendwie an die Grundsteuer angefasst wird?
Ja, das würde ich nicht über den sagen wollen, aber das ist etwas, was für, zumindest aus der Sicht der Steuerberatung auch nicht wirklich spannend ist, weil bloß hinten die Zahl zu verändern, das macht uns keine Probleme.
Das ist nicht spannend. Da müssen wir noch drauf kommen, was spannend bei Steuerberatungen ist.
Ja, das ist halt einfach nicht spannend zu sagen, ich ändere hinten die Zahl, aber die Frage, wie ermittle ich die Steuer? Die ist bei der Grundsteuer, die gehört zu den Steuern, die ist relativ stabil. Das ist etwas, wo man nicht wirklich nicht viel machen kann. Da kann man nicht so richtig viel gestalten. Also einmal im Jahr überlegt man sich, ob man mal eine Herabsetzung beantragen kann. Und ansonsten ist das so eine Sache, die unter Fanativen läuft.
Substanzsteuer hast du das genannt, die Grundsteuer, und du hast auch die Vermögenssteuer, eine Substanzsteuer genannt, die jetzt alle in der Top-Level-Kategorie Besitzsteuer sind, um die Orientierung weiterhin zu haben. Vermögenssteuer, da wird viel darüber diskutiert in Deutschland, aber geben tut es sie de facto derzeit nicht. Gabs aber mal.
Die Gabs mal abgeschafft wurde, die de facto des Bundesverfassungsgerichts. Das hatte den folgenden Hintergrund, dass man bei Grundstücken, die auch der Vermögenssteuer unterliegen, ein großes Problem hat, die wirklich dem Verkehrswert zu unterwerfen. Also, wie viel ist so ein Grundstück wert? Und das ist deshalb so schwierig. Bei der Grundstücke machst du das aber auch kein Problem, weil ich dort einen Vergleich haben muss zu Wertpapieren. Bei Wertpapieren ist das relativ einfach. Da kann ich mir nämlich einfach auf den Tipo-Auszug gucken und kann sagen, so viel ist das bei dem Papier zum Stichtag wert gewesen. Und kann da drauf sagen, okay, dann zahlen wir da drauf einen Betrag steuern. Das ist bei einem Grundstück viel schwieriger. Und ist mal schon lange klar, dass die Grundstücke im Verhältnis gesehen zu beispielsweise Wertpapieren viel weniger besteuert werden. Also es war steuerlich günstiger, sein Geld in ein Grundstück anzulegen als in Aktien. Und da hat das Bundesverfassungsgericht gesagt, das geht nicht. Das verbietet der Gleichheitsgrundsatz. Wenn, dann muss das gleichmäßig besteuern. Und das ist mit einer der beiden großen Gründe, warum es bis heute die Vermögensteuer nicht wieder gibt, weil keiner bisher so eine richtige Idee hat, wie wir insbesondere Grundstücke so bewerten, dass sie Firmen, das wäre nämlich der nächste große Teil, Firmen, Aktien, dass man das wirklich sagen kann, die sind jetzt auch gleichmäßig besteuert. Und der zweite Teil, der in den Tageszeitungen nicht ganz so oben steht, die Vermögensteuer war nicht wirklich lohnenswert. Was man bei den Steuern nämlich immer rechnen muss, ist, was kriege ich für die Steuerung?
Lohnt es sich überhaupt, sie zu erheben?
Ja, was muss ich an Verwaltungsaufwand reinstecken und was bleibt unter dem Strich von der Steuer übrig? Da muss man sagen, die Vermögensteuer gehörte zu den Steuern, die schlichtweg nicht lukrativ waren. Da blieb nicht viel übrig, weil es war damals schon so, dass es ein irrsinniger Verwaltungsakt war, zu ermitteln, wer wie viel bezahlen muss. Und wenn ich jetzt sagen würde, ich würde beispielsweise die Grundstücke, ich könnte sagen, okay, dann muss ich Sachverständige durch die Straßen schicken und die ganzen Dinge bewerten lassen, das würde einen derartigen Aufwand machen, dass da vermutlich nicht mehr wirklich was übrig bleibt. Also das ist, politisch kann man sich ja drüber streiten, ob die gewollt ist oder nicht, aber man muss einfach sagen...
Das ist eigentlich auch so ein Dauerbrenner, so ein Wahlkampf-Thema, wir müssen die Vermögenssteuer wieder einfüllen, blablabla und die reichen nach mir alles und so.
Genau, aber die erzählen, die diese einfüllen wollen, die sollen...
Nicht wie sie es machen würden.
So, dass es dem Verfassungsgericht auch standhalten würde. Und das ist aus meiner Sicht immer politisch ein bisschen Schaumschlägerei.
Forscht eigentlich irgendjemand sowas? Gibt es sowas wie Steuerforschung? Jaja.
Also es gibt zwei große Teile, sowohl die Betriebswirte als auch die Juristen, die sich da ganz fleißig drum bemühen, wo es natürlich Steuerrechtslehrstöder gibt. Und aus verschiedenen Blickwinkeln versuchen Steuern auch zu erforschen.
Aber bei Vermögenssteuern ist noch kein was passendes eingefallen.
Wie gesagt, es scheitert halt an Praktikabilitätsgründen. Also es ist ja nicht so, dass man es nicht könnte, aber man muss sich dann eben den Falschein lohnen, den man aufhört.
Welchen Aufwand hat es? Jetzt gibt es andere Besitzsteuern, also gibt es noch andere Substanzsteuern?
Also da fiel mir jetzt nicht so richtig was noch ein.
Also Land haben oder geldwerte Dinge haben, das ist sozusagen das, was man als Substanz ausmachen kann. Das könnte halt zwei mögliche Steuern zur Folge haben. Grundsteuer, Vermögensteuer. Die eine haben wir, die andere haben wir nicht. Haben wir jetzt gehört. Neben diesen Substanzsteuern gibt es noch weitere Steuern, die auch dem Besitz zugeordnet werden können. Was ist das?
Dem Besitz, ja, das sind sogenannte Ertragssteuern. Was eigentlich jedem, der arbeiten geht, betrifft, ist die sogenannte Einkommensteuer.
Also Ertragssteuern, das heißt, Besitzsteuer geht immer darum, was man hat oder haben könnte. Weil in dem Moment, wo man ja schon bei der Einnahme zahlt, dann erreicht es ja nie den Status eines Besitzes.
Der Begriff hinkt, das ist richtig, weil ich besteuere bei diesen Ertragssteuern den Ertrag, also die Quelle an der es sprudel sind. Ich nehme also etwas weg von dem, was mir zufließt. Und wie gesagt, die Einkommensteuer ist das, was jeden treffen dürfte, der in irgendeiner Form Arbeit nachgeht. Das ist unsere Hauptsteuer. Das betrifft alle, die selbstständigen Einkünften nachgehen, Gewerbebetrieben, Kapitalvermögen, Vermietungen, Verpackungen.
Hauptsteuer, weil es alle betrifft oder Hauptsteuer, weil es einen Großteil des Geldes ausmacht, der überhaupt generiert wird?
Sowohl als auch. Also es ist sowohl ein Großteil des Geldes als auch das, was jeden trifft. Dann kommen wir später nochmal zu Umsatzsteuer, das ist eben so der zweite Teil, der auch einen Großteil darstellt und auch jeden betrifft. Wie gesagt, die Einkommensteuer darf vielleicht gleich mal einem immer wieder gehörten Irrtum aufzuräumen. Die Lohnsteuer, das ist keine eigene Steuer. Das ist lediglich eine Vorauszahlung im Rahmen der Einkommensteuer. Also die Lohnsteuer fällt immer dann, wenn ich einer abhängigen Beschäftigung nachgehe, also ganz normaler Angestellter oder Arbeiter bin, dann wird von meinem Lohn sogenannte Lohnsteuer einbehalten und das Finanzamt abgeführt. Das ist aber eine Einkommensteuervorauszahlung. Bei den Selbstständigen läuft das halt so, dass die vierteljährlich ihre Einkommensteuervorauszahlungen leisten müssen. Ist aber, das Prinzip bleibt dasselbe, es ist auch dasselbe Gesetz. Und am Jahresende, wenn ich dann, was man früher mal den Lohnsteuerjahresausgleich macht, oder jetzt mal eine Einkommensteuererklärung mache, da wird dann geguckt, ok, das hast du das Jahr über wirklich insgesamt verdient, das wird festgesetzt und davon wird abgezogen deine Lohnsteuer oder eben deine Einkommensteuervorauszahlungen. Und das, was dann übrig bleibt, entweder kriegst du noch was zurück oder musst noch was nachzahlen. Das ist also, du bist ein bisschen wie bei der Pistole.
Ok, also die Steuer, die dahintersteht, ist dieselbe. Lohnsteuer ist eigentlich nur ein anderes Einzugsverfahren.
Genau.
In dem vorher schon mal was regelmäßig, weil es eh absehbar ist, dass ein bestimmter Teil dieses Lohns prozentual als Einkommensteuer hängen bleibt. Deswegen holt man ihn sich irgendwie gleich. Dann braucht man am Schluss nur noch über die Differenzen zu reden und nicht ewig warten. Aber eigentlich fällt das alles in diesen Sack Einkommensteuer. Was ist jetzt die, also was ist sozusagen die Aussage der Einkommensteuer? Die Einkommensteuer ist, du tust was, du kriegst was dafür und dafür, dass du was bekommst, dafür musst du auch was geben. Das heißt, hier ist sozusagen die Idee, die, dass man den, wer auch immer irgendwie entlohnt wird, einen Teil dieses Lohns bereits einbehält als Beitrag für die Gesellschaft. Weil das die eigentliche Wertschöpfung ist.
Genau, aus deiner Wertschöpfung musst du was abgeben, mit dem Einbehalten, wie gesagt, bei der Lohnsteuer oder bei den Selbstständigen, die müssen dann eben von ihrem Gewinn etwas abgeben an den Staat, damit dort eben das Gemeinwohl in irgendeiner Weise finanziert werden kann.
Das heißt, Einkommensteuer bezieht sich eigentlich nur auf Festbeschäftigte?
Nein, nein, das bezieht sich, es gibt sogenannte sieben Einkunftsarten, alles was darunter fällt, muss entrichtet werden. Das sind eben die unselbstständigen Einkünfte, Vermietungen und Verpachtungen, Kapitaleinkünfte, die sonstigen Einkünfte, wobei das ist ein spezielles Teil, da soll man nicht glauben, dass da alles darunter fällt, was darunter nicht fällt, das wäre nicht richtig. Die gewerblichen Einkünfte, die selbstständigen Einkünfte und jetzt müsste ich irgendwie noch einen in der Aufzählung vergessen haben, Landen, Forstwirtschaft fehlt noch darunter, genau. Also das sind so und alles was unter diese Bereiche fällt, das unterliegt der Einkommensteuer, wenn es durch eine natürliche Person, also durch nicht durch GmbH, sondern durch Menschen erwirtschaftet wurde. Und das muss man eben auch sagen, das ist ein zentraler Punkt, bestimmter der Steuergesetzgebung, was nicht unter diese sieben Einkunftsarten fällt, unterliegt auch nicht der Einkommensteuer. Beispiel ist dafür der Lotteriegewinn. Der fällt nicht drunter.
Was ist denn bitte unselbstständige Einkünfte?
Das ist der Arbeitnehmer. Unselbstständige Einkünfte sind der Arbeitnehmer.
Ach so, weil man nicht selber denkt, sondern nur gesagt bekommt, hier tue das Schlagerhammer auf Amboss. Und Lotteriegewinn?
Der ist in diesem Gesetz nicht aufgeführt und deshalb unterliegt auch nicht der Einkommensteuer. Der ist dann einkommensteuerlich steuerfrei. Also nicht steuerpflichtig, müsste man juristisch genau sagen.
Auch wenn es da bestimmt irgendwelche Lotterie-Steuern gibt.
Das gibt es auch noch, das sind dann so, muss man schon sagen, Lotterie- und Rennwettsteuern, das sind so diese echten Demensteuern.
Aber das bezieht sich dann wiederum auf die Betreiber. Bleiben wir erstmal bei der Einkommensteuer. Okay, also unselbstständige Einköpfe, klar, wenn ich also beschäftigt bin, selbstständige Einköpfe, wenn ich selbstständig bin, wenn ich sozusagen selber mich drum kümmere oder was.
Ja, auch dort, also es gibt zwei Gruppen.
Das ist dann Mitdenken.
Das ist dann Mitdenken, das sind die Gewerblichen und die selbstständigen Einkünfte. Auch da gibt es dann oft eine Begriffsverwechslung. Also selbstständig sind die beide.
Gewerblichen meinste jetzt?
Sowohl die Gewerblichen als auch die selbstständigen Einkünfte. Also was unter die selbstständigen Einkünfte gefällt. Selbstständige Einkünfte, das sind sogenannte Katalogberufe, Rechtsanwälte, Steuerberater, Ärzte, Dolmetscher, Fluglotsen fallen komischerweise auch drunter. Da gibt es einen ganzen Katalog und ähnliche Berufskünstler fallen auch drunter.
Podcaster auch? Gehen wir nicht darüber.
Und die Gewerblichen Einkünfte, das ist eben das, was man sich sonst, also wenn jemand sagt, ich bin selbstständig, ein Großteil der Fälle wird vermutlich gewerbliche Einkünfte haben und nicht selbstständige Einkünfte. Der Unterschied zwischen diesen beiden Kategorien liegt hauptsächlich gar nicht in der Einkommensteuer, sondern in der Gewerbesteuer. Wer gewerbliche Einkünfte erzielt, muss Gewerbesteuer noch zusätzlich zahlen. Wer selbstständige Einkünfte erzielt, braucht das nicht.
Warum?
Das habe ich auch noch nie richtig verstanden.
Das beruhigt mich und das beunruhigt mich ein bisschen.
Mir als Anwalt soll es natürlich recht sein, dass ich nicht der Gewerbesteuerpflicht unterliege.
Weil es ja sozusagen eine zusätzliche Steuer ist. Das heißt, bei den Katalogberufen fällt einfach eine bestimmte Steuer überhaupt nicht an. Auch wenn man ja eigentlich, jetzt aus meiner naiven Betrachtung heraus, nicht wirklich andere Sachen macht, als andere Leute in ihren Berufen auch tun. Nur, dass meiner mit einem Titel fest in irgendeiner Liste drin steht und Leute, die sich ihren Beruf im Wesentlichen selbst ausdenken und immer nicht wissen, was sie auf ihre Visitenkarten draufschreiben sollen, natürlich von so einem Katalog nicht erfasst werden.
Der Handwerksmeister fällt auch unter der Gewerbesteuer. Und der darf sehr wohl was auf seine Visitenkarte schreiben.
Ja, aber wo kommt denn das denn her? Ist das jetzt irgendwie so Privilegien-Schutz oder was? Also, ich meine, gibt es da irgendeine Argumentation?
Die gibt es natürlich. Man hat ursprünglich gesagt, dass gewerbliche Berufe das Gemeinwesen viel stärker belasten. Weil Handwerksbetriebe oder größere Fabriken, die belasten die Kanalisation mehr, die brauchen größere Straßen und und und.
Dann sagen wir noch mal ein paar von diesen Katalogberufen.
Rechtsanwälte, Steuerberater, Wirtschaftsprüfe, Ärzte, Zahnärzte, Veterinärmediziner, Dolmetscher, Fluglotsen, ich glaube, die Hebammen sind noch drunter. Und dann Musisch, also der Bereich Kunst.
Also die Rechtsanwälte, die belasten nicht das Gemeinwesen.
Ja, wie gesagt, das ist etwas für Sie. Das halte ich auf eine steile These. Teilweise noch die freien Ingenieure, die fallen auch nicht drunter.
Aber im Prinzip ist das bunte Tüte und irgendwie unklar, oder?
Deswegen sage ich ja, ich kann es auch nicht nachvollziehen. Ich war selbst mal eine Zeit lang Hausverwalter, bin dafür gewerbesteuerpflichtig gewesen und bin dann gewechselt in eine Großkanzlei. Die Hausverwaltung bestand aus mir und einem Angestellten. Dafür musste ich Gewerbestell zahlen. Ich habe nicht verstanden, wo ich da die Straße irgendwie mehr belastet habe als irgendwer anders. Und bin danach in eine Großkanzlei gewechselt. Die haben hier in Berlin ein eigenes Gebäude. Also die haben hier wirklich Verkehr. Da passiert was. Und die liegen zwar auch der Gewerbestell, das liegt aber in ihren Rechtsformen, aber vom Ansatz her, wenn sie sich als Partnerschaft organisiert hätten und nicht als Aktiengesellschaft, dann würden sie nicht der Gewerbestell unterliegen. Und das ist etwas, was ich auch nicht verstehe. Also ich verstehe auch nicht, warum meine Arbeit als Rechtsanwalt wirklich eine andere ist von einem Handwerksmeister oder von einem Hausverwalter oder einem Podcast. Also das verstehe ich auch nicht so richtig. Dass die Gewerbesteuer sich nach wie vor hartnäckig hält, hat sicherlich zwei Gründe. Zum einen, die Gewerbesteuer ist eine Steuer, die in die Kommunen fließt. Das sorgt für die Gemeindefinanzierung. Wo ich der Meinung bin, das könnten wir auch anders handhaben, kriegen sie mehr von der Einkommenssteuer ab. Können wir die auch ein bisschen anheben.
Kriegen die denn überhaupt was von der Einkommenssteuer ab?
Die kriegen auch was ab, aber an sie einen geringen Anteil.
Ah, verstehe.
Und der zweite Teil ist, man muss sich ja noch mal angucken, wer so im Bundestag sitzt. Also, das sind ja Juristen und Lehrer, die durften damit die größten Gruppen darstellen.
Ah, kommen wir zu den Verschwörungstheorien.
Das ist keine Verschwörungstheorie, aber ich meine, da brauche ich ja nur mal die Liste angucken und die Frage stellen, wer hat denn da welche Lobby.
Was ist mit Beamten? Die sind ja auch immer noch so eine Sondernummer.
Also steuerlich nicht, weil die unterliegen ganz normal der Einkommenssteuer. Das sind unselbstständige Einkünfte. Also wie andere Arbeitnehmer auch. Worauf du anspielst, ist mehr eine Frage des Sozialversicherungsrecht und Rentenversicherungsrecht. Das ist also nochmal eine ganz andere Wiese.
Okay, da wollen wir jetzt erstmal nicht ran. An den Kuchen. Aber gut, das ist auf jeden Fall schon mal sehr gut und wichtig, dass wir das mal klargestellt haben. Das heißt, ich fasse nochmal zusammen, also wir haben die Einkommensteuer betrifft irgendwie alle. Ist eine der wichtigsten Steuern, also eine Haupteinnahmequellen auch dieses Staates. Es gibt eine ganze Reihe von verschiedenen Arten von Einkünften. Wenn man unter einer dieser sieben fällt, dann hat man überhaupt erst mal Einkommensteuer zu entrichten. Wenn man sein Leben im Wesentlichen aus Lotteriegewinnen bezieht, dann hat man Glück. Fällt dir noch so spontan irgendwas ein, was nicht unter diese Einkünfte fällt, aber trotzdem irgendwie regelmäßige Zuwendungen betrifft?
Also, regelmäßig nicht. Alles, was regelmäßig ist, wird damit abgefackelt.
Alles, was so einmal kommt, Spenden, tralala und so weiter.
Also, die Fälle, die dann wirklich nicht steuerbar sind, die unterliegen dann der Erbschaften Schenkungssteuer.
Eigentlich gibt es nur Lotteriegewinne.
Das ist sozusagen die einzige Möglichkeit, die spontan einfällt.
Und dann gibt es diese Sonderform, gewerbliche Einkünfte. Und wenn man da auf dieses Schema passt, dann fällt außerdem noch die Gewerbesteuer an. Das heißt, man zahlt noch mal extra eine Ausgabe und das ist dann sozusagen teurer, so ein Business zu verfolgen, ein solches Business zu unterliegen und durchzuführen als andere Geschichten, wenn man Pilot wäre.
Richtig. Die Gewerbesteuer, das muss man immer dazu sagen, die Gewerbesteuer wird teilweise auf die Einkommensteuer angerechnet. Also es findet so eine Reduzierung noch mal statt im Rahmen der Einkommensteuer. Aber das soll nicht darüber hinwegtäuschen, es gibt für diese Personengruppen eine besondere Steuern.
Aber es gibt ja ein interessanter Aspekt, den du noch aufgebracht hast, das ist dieses, wer kriegt die eigentlich? Das haben wir ja bisher noch so gar nicht durchdringen lassen. Also dieses föderale System, wir haben irgendwie die Länder, wir haben die Kommunen, wir haben den Staat, also den Bundesstaat. Und noch gut, aber Steuern auf europäischer Ebene in dem Sinne gibt es ja nicht.
Ja, die kriegen ein bisschen von der Umsatzsteuer ab und von den Zöllen.
Ah, okay, Europa können wir ja nochmal machen, ich will jetzt nicht so viele Klammern aufmachen. Auf jeden Fall.
Also das ist vielleicht nicht einhakenhaft, das ist dieser ganze Komplex Bund-Länder-Finanzausgleich. Wer kriegt was von Topf? Das System ist nahezu undurchschaubar. Also es gibt zwar schon so grobe Einordungen, wo man sagen kann, der kriegt was wie, aber wenn man da mal tiefer einsteigt, das ist verworren. Also das ist wirklich Spaghetti-Politik, die da betrieben wird. Wie gesagt, es gibt schon so grobe Richtungen, aber das ist eine ganz eigene Wiese, wo da was wie genau langläuft an Zahlungsströmen.
Gut, um diese Einkunftsarten nochmal abzuschließen, du hast da noch Vermietung, Verpachtung genannt. Das heißt, wenn ich jemanden etwas vermiete, sprich Wohnungsmiete zum Beispiel, aber auch Gewerberaummiete oder sowas?
Ja, das unterliegt in den Einkünften aus Vermietung und Verpachtung.
Kapitaleinkünfte? Zinsen?
Zinsen, Erträge. Aktiengewinne? Ja, wenn ich aus den Verkäufen Aktien habe, dann sind das sogenannte sonstige Einkünfte. Wenn ich aber die Dividenden aus meinem Aktien bekomme, das sind Einkünfte aus Kapitalvermögen. Oder wenn ich an einer GmbH beteiligt bin und die schüttet aus, das sind auch Einkünfte aus Kapitalvermögen.
Ah, und einfach so Sparbuchzinsen oder so? Also Geld haben, das fällt eigentlich auch darunter.
Das fällt auch darunter.
Sind wir dann doch wieder so ein bisschen bei dieser Vermögenssteuer? Wenn ich Geld habe, dann...
Nee, weil da... Ich besteuere ja nicht, wenn ich 100 Euro vom Sparbuch habe, besteuere ich nicht die 100 Euro, sondern ich besteuere die Zinsen nicht von der Bank bekomme.
Ah, verstehe, okay.
Und da gibt es seit...
Ah ja, stimmt, und gibt mir die Bank keine Zinsen, dann hab ich da auch nichts zu zahlen.
Okay. Und da gibt es eine Besonderheit, während wir sonst eine Einkommenssteuer, sogenannte Progressionen haben, also wir fangen bei ein bisschen Steuern an, und das wird immer mehr prozentual, je nach wie ich verdiene, hat sich das bei den Kapitalenkünften abgekoppelt seit Anfang letzten Jahres. Dort gibt es jetzt auch einen festen Steuersatz, 25% fix, sogenannte Abgeltungssteuer. Und die Abgeltungssteuer sorgt dafür, dass wenn ich Einkünfte aus Kapitalvermögen habe, sind die mit 25% abgegolten. Das bedeutet, auch wenn ich sonst einen Einkommensteuersatz habe, weil ich sonst auch noch Millionen verdiene und sonst irgendwie über die 40%, also bei den fast 47% liege, also mit dieser sogenannten Reichensteuer noch dazu, bei den Kapitalenkünften habe ich eine 25%.
Warum?
Ich würde auch lieber sagen, das habe ich auch nicht richtig verstanden.
Das sind immer die interessanten Aspekte, auf die wir hier kommen.
Also natürlich, das Prinzip ist schon klar, ich arbeite damit, aber der Ansatzpunkt war, dass man gesagt hat, man muss die niedriger besteuern, um die Besteuerung der Kapitalenkünfte zu sichern. Da immer dieser schöne Spruch, Kapital ist flüchtig, man flüchtet sonst mit dem Kapital ins Ausland. Und man möchte eben mit einer sehr einfachen Steuer und mit einer Steuer, die besonders niedrig ist, dafür sorgen, dass die Kapitalenkünfte hier auch stattfinden. Genau, dass sie hier besteuert werden und dass eben keine Flucht ins Ausland stattfindet.
Also bei Kapitalsteuer steckt auch so ein bisschen Kapitulationssteuer sozusagen mit drin.
Das wird es ja gut treffen, ja. Und warum ich gesagt habe, das verstehe ich auch nicht so richtig, das hat schon, finde ich, ein gewisses Gerechtigkeitsproblem. Jemand, der eine Million Einkünfte aus unselbstständiger Arbeit wie ein Vorstandsmitglied erwirtschaftet, zahlt dafür deutlich mehr Steuern als jemand, der eine Million aus Dividenden seiner Aktienpakete erwirtschaftet. Und das ist etwas, wo ich mal sagen...
Wird jemand eigentlich auch gar nichts tut in dem Sinne?
Das kommt noch dazu, ja. Oder jemand, der aus Einkünften, aus Vermietungen, Verpachtungen, wenn man es damit vergleicht, da könnte man ja auch sagen, der tut auch nicht wirklich was, einfach nur, weil er ein Wohngebäude vermietet und dafür eine Million kriegt. Der muss mehr zahlen als jemand, der einfach nur Aktien hält und Dividenden kassiert. Aber das haben wir eben, das geht immer so. Und so sei es. Wir können da ja auch keine Politik gestalten.
Okay, na gut, aber so Mietsachen, die tendieren ja auch dazu, vor sich hin zu rotten. Das machen ja dann die Aktien nicht so ohne Weiteres.
Ja, wobei das, was ich in die Mietsache reinstecke, um sie vor dem Pfarrer zu schützen, das wird ja von meinem Ertrag abgezogen. Also besteuert wird hier nur das, was am Ende der Strecke übrig bleibt.
Und die Land- und Forstwirtschaft, die ist nochmal separat?
Die ist separat und das ist steuerlich einer der skurrilsten Gebiete, glaube ich. Weil es bei der Land- und Forstwirtschaft findet de facto eine Subventionierung statt über das Steuerrecht. Die haben also ganz eigenartige Methoden, wie sie ihren Gewinn ermitteln. Das müssen sie nämlich nicht zwangsläufig, indem sie sagen, ich habe am Ende der Strecke das Geld übrig gehabt. Ich habe keine Mandanten aus der Land- und Forstwirtschaft, das kann mir auch hier in Berlin nicht passieren, deswegen bin ich da also keinem Hof drin.
Ich habe von so Hinterhofgärten gehört.
Da müsste ich auch einen Kollegen, den ich dir noch weiterempfehlen müsste, aber die rechnen dann also ganz skurrige Sachen um mit irgendwelchen Vieheinheiten. Da wird dann also irgendwie ein Schwein umgerechnet in drei Viertel ganz und so was. Also das ist... Drei Viertel ganz?
Ganz wie das Tier ganz.
Ja genau, da gibt es ein Bewertungsgesetz, also das kann man sich nur jedem mal empfehlen. Ich glaube, das ist die Anlage 1 oder die Anlage 3 zum Bewertungsgesetz, da werden sogenannte Vieheinheiten umgerechnet und da kann man also verschiedene Tiere miteinander umrechnen. Also irgendwie eine Kuh ist eine Vieheinheit und drei Schweine sind dann irgendwie eine Kuh und das ist also völlig abgefahren.
Ah, wird das auch bei Beleidigungsstrafen herangezogen? Sie haben sie eine dumme Kuh genannt, das ist irgendwie mindestens drei Viertel ganz. Was ist der Effekt? Also du meinst, da findet eine Subvention statt. Also im Prinzip wird der Land- und Forstwirtschaft eine Möglichkeit gegeben, weniger Steuern zu zahlen, auf welchen Umrechnungsbasen auch immer. Wahrscheinlich einfach mit der Intention, dass man sagt, ihr bestellt unser Futter, das ist gut, oder was?
Ich würde den Begriff Lobby da auch nicht so ganz von der Hand weisen wollen. Und natürlich, weil es auch eine Grundversorgung darstellt.
Ich meine, es ist natürlich auch immer viel Geschichte mit drin und letzten Endes, es gab mal eine Zeit, da gab es sowas wie Industrie und Service-Gesellschaft nicht, sondern da bestand wahrscheinlich im Wesentlichen diese ganze Tätigkeit, man tut was heißt, dass man da irgendwelche Ähren eingesammelt hat und Körner auf die Erde geschmissen hat und so weiter. Jetzt haben wir diese ganze moderne Welt der Wertschöpfung, die ja irgendwie ihre Explosion findet, eben in diesem ganzen unverständlichen Kapitalmarkt, wo überhaupt keiner sich mehr irgendwie bewegt, sondern eigentlich nur noch die Computer dafür sorgen, dass Geld verdient wird. Kann man mir vorstellen, dass das einfach von daher seine Sonderrolle über die Jahre so beibehalten hat?
Ja, also ich glaube, es wird halt einfach sehr arg verteidigt von bestimmten Gruppen. Und sich deshalb auch keiner so richtig rantraut, das mal zu reformieren. Das wird ein Ansatzpunkt sein und ein zweiter Ansatzpunkt. Diese, was ja auch teilweise schon angegriffen wird, diese Form der Sequenzierung, die meines Erachtens nicht anzunehmen, noch bestritten wird, dass so eine Sequenzierung stattfindet, könnte man aufgrund der Europäischen Union so nicht durchführen oder nicht so einfach durchführen, wenn man sie nicht so versteckt machen würde. Also das ist ein offenes Geheimnis, das so konventioniert wird über diese Form. Aber man könnte eben nicht sagen, wir besteuern euch jetzt wie jeden normalen Gewerbebetrieb, egal was ihr da eigentlich macht. Weil wir der Meinung sind, Bauern finden wir klasse, drücken wir jetzt jedem dafür ein Hundi in die Hand, dass er eben Bauer ist. Das ginge nicht ganz so einfach. Was ich aus meiner Sicht zumindest mal das faire System finde, weil das ist dann einfach offen. Das versteht dann jeder.
Jetzt fällt mir noch mal ein, wir hatten ja über diese Abgeltungssteuer geredet, diese 25% auf die Kapitaleinkünfte. Es gab ja auch lange Zeit diese Chimiere der Quellensteuer.
Ja, also ich meine sicherlich Zinsabschlachsteuer und Kapitalertragsteuer.
Ich wollte es jetzt nicht so kompliziert aussehen.
Ja, ja, das ist richtig, weil Quellensteuer ist mehr so ein Problem im Ausland, aber Zinsabschlachsteuer, Kapitalertragsteuer, das ist, wer man so will, der Vorgänger rechtstechnisch ist es eigentlich auch noch eine Kapitalertragsteuer teilweise, weil es da geregelt wird. Aber das Prinzip dort ist ähnlich wie bei der Lohnsteuer. Ich zahle Steuern voraus über die Zinsabschlachsteuer und am Ende der Strecke gucke ich dann, was ich habe ich insgesamt verdient, dazu zählen dann auch die Kapitalenkünfte. Und setze die Einkommensteuer fest und davon wird dann eben Lohnsteuer, Zinsabschlachsteuer und sonstige Vorausseilungen in Abzug gebracht. Und das ist ein Verfahren, was wir auch dem Verfassungsgericht zu verdanken haben, weil die irgendwann gesagt haben, Moment mal, das gab es eben mal früher nicht und das hat dazu geführt, dass natürlich keiner seine Zinsen angegeben hat. Und dann hat das Verfassungsgericht gesagt, das ist auch Form einer ungerechten Besteuerung, wenn ich den Leuten das bescheißen derart leicht mache. Und dann kam eben die Zinsabschlachsteuer, um das vereinfacht zu machen. Heute hätten wir da technisch noch viel andere Möglichkeiten, um das Problem zu umgehen. Und das ist dann eben so Thema Datenschutz auch, dass die Banken de facto jetzt schon alle Einkünfte melden. Aber also man hätte das mit dem heutigen technischen Stand damals vielleicht auch anders lösen können. Man hat es eben damals mit der Zinsabschlachsteuer gelöst.
So, das ist also jetzt Einkommensteuer gewesen, die wir sozusagen als weitere, das war jetzt sozusagen Ertragssteuer. Du hast auch andere Ertragssteuern.
Die Körperschaftssteuer wäre da erwähnt wird. Das ist quasi die Einkommensteuer der juristischen Personen, also insbesondere der GmbHs und der Aktiengesellschaften.
Und Einkommensteuer bezieht sich von daher immer so auf einen richtigen Menschen.
Auf natürliche Personen, also auf Menschen. Während die Körperschaftssteuer auf die juristischen Personen abstellt, wie gesagt, die Aktiengesellschaften, die müssen auf ihren Gewinn Körperschaftssteuer zahlen und Gewerbesteuer.
GmbH auch.
Die GmbH auch. Das ist auch eine juristische Person. Wie gesagt, die zahlen Körperschaftssteuer. Und die zahlen eben auch Gewerbesteuer. Die GBR, das ist so eine Sonderzahl. Die Zahlen sind zwar gewerbesteuerpflichtig unter Umständen, wenn sie gewerblichen Tätigkeiten nachgehen. Aber bei der Einkommenssteuer ist es so, dass ich dort nicht die Personengesellschaften besteuere, wie GBR, OHG, Kommetitgesellschaft, sondern die Gesellschafter. Es ist steuerlich so, dass ich durchgucke, was kommt beim Gesellschafter an? Das heißt, die GBR selbst ist nicht Einkommenssteuersubjekt.
Ja, und damit auch nicht Körperschaftssteuersubjekt.
Auch nicht, nein.
Aber die einzelnen Personen, die die GBR ausmachen, sind dann einfach noch mal Einkommenssteuer.
Genau.
Aber das Konstrukt als solches ist an der Stelle... Man redet ja auch von einer Personengesellschaft, das ist richtig der Begriff. Und von daher betrifft es sozusagen nur die Einkommenssteuer. Aber die Einkommenssteuer nicht auf die GBR angewinne, sondern eben einfach auf die Gesellschafter angewinne.
Und wenn ein Gesellschafter in der GmbH ist, das ist auch bei der GBR möglich, dann eben muss die entsprechende Körperschaftssteuer zahlen. Das mache ich über eine sogenannte gesonderte, einheitliche Feststellung, also ein etwas kompliziertes Verfahren, wo ich dann durch diese Personengesellschaft so durchgucke und mir angucke, was kommt mit einem einzelnen Gesellschafter an.
Und was ist nun die Eigenschaft dieser Körperschaftssteuer? Also gut, sie bezieht sich jetzt darauf, aber was wird dann da? Also im Prinzip die Einkommenssteuer für die GmbH. Das heißt, man nimmt dann einfach sozusagen die Firma als Ganzes, so wie sie eben mit all ihren Mitarbeitern wirkt. Und dann hat die halt auch Einnahmen?
Ja, die hat dann Einnahmen, die kann auch davon ihre Ausgaben absetzen, hat dann irgendwie einen Gewinn und den besteuere ich da. Und der Grund, dass es die Körperschaftssteuer gibt, liegt einfach daran, dass es strukturell andere Merkmale gibt bei der GmbH als bei einer natürlichen Person, weil wir dort einiges haben, was anders ist. Also wir haben beispielsweise einen festen Steuersatz und wir haben keine Progression wie bei der Einkommensteuer. Und wir haben viele Sachen, die wir in der Einkommensteuer, also es gibt zwar eine Überleitungsvorschrift auch von der Körperschaftssteuer an das Einkommensteuergesetz, aber man muss einfach sagen, es gibt viele Probleme, die wir in der Einkommensteuer nicht haben, die wir dort haben, haben wir in der Körperschaftssteuer nicht. Als einfachstes Beispiel, ich kann Krankheitskosten, die mir nicht von der Krankenkasse erstattet werden, kann ich in einem bestimmten Rahmen als sogenannte außergewöhnliche Belastung von der Steuer absetzen. Da gehen wir einfach nicht krank. Das Thema wird einfach mal... Dafür habe ich ein paar andere Probleme bei der Körperschaft, die mir bei einer natürlichen Person so nicht zum Tragen kommen, beispielsweise, dass eine Körperschaft nicht stirbt. Man kann sie zwar liquidieren, aber grundsätzlich ist sie erst mal unendlich von der Zeitdauer her. Und ich kann die Gesellschaft daran auch beliebig auswechseln. Das bringt einige steuerliche Besonderheiten, die man bei der GmbH berücksichtigen muss. Oder dass ich von GmbH zu GmbH einfach immer weiter Gewinne reichen kann. Das sind so Themenkomplexe, die ich dort als Spezifiker habe und deshalb auch in eigenes Gesetz gießen muss.
Jetzt vielleicht noch mal zu diesem Warum. Also Körperschaftssteuer ist im Prinzip die Einkommenssteuer für Firmen. Warum erforderlich?
Naja, dass ich die besteuere im Hintergrund. Ich erziele Geld, also muss ich was ins Gemeinwesen abgeben.
Man könnte ja jetzt argumentieren, in so einer Firma arbeiten ja auch Leute. Und die kriegen ja das Geld durch diese Firma und zahlen das ja. Und wenn die Firma Gewinne macht, dann gehen diese Gewinne ja auch zu irgendjemanden.
Die gehen dann zu dem Gesellschafter.
Der müsste die ja dann auch wieder versteuern.
Der muss diese Gewinne dann auch wieder versteuern, das ist richtig. Früher hat man diese Doppelbesteuerung, also da gab es schon in der Vergangenheit verschiedene Methoden, wie man diese Doppelbesteuerung, dass ich einmal die GmbH mit der Körperschaftssteuer belaste und wenn sie dann in die Gesellschaft ausgeschüttet wird, nochmal mit der Einkommensteuer belastet wird, wie ich das umgehe. Ganz früher hatten wir das sogenannte Anrichtungsverfahren, da wurden dann Teile der Steuern wieder angerechnet. Das wurde immer komplizierter, irgendwann hat man sich davon getrennt, hat das sogenannte Halbeinkünfte-Verfahren eingeführt. Da war es dann so, dass ich gesagt habe, okay, weil es oben schon mal bei der GmbH besteuert wird, muss ich beim Gesellschaft dann nur noch die Hälfte besteuern. Das passt dann so ungefähr. Und jetzt haben wir so ein genanntes Teilankünfte-Verfahren. Also auch jetzt wird dafür gesorgt, dass diese Doppelbelastung von der GmbH und von dem Gesellschafter ausgeglichen wird in einem pauschalierten Verfahren. Der Grund wird sicherlich auch der sein, wenn ich bei einer GmbH einen Gewinn mache und würde es erst besteuern, wenn es beim Gesellschafter ankommt, dann würde ich dann auch immer auf die Besteuerung verzichten, solange der nicht ausschüttet. Ich muss ja nicht ausschütten. Also das Geld kann ja in der GmbH bleiben. Die Körperschaftssteuer besteuert aber jedes Jahr den Gewinn der GmbH, ob die ausschüttet oder nicht. Nur bei der Ausschüttung kommt es dazu, dass der Gesellschafter nochmal zur Steuer herangezogen wird. Wenn der sagt, ich glaube Microsoft hat noch nie ausgeschüttet, dann bräuchten die nie Steuernzahlen. Das Unternehmen wird immer mehr wert, aber ich zahl keine Steuern.
Ist denn das die einzige Steuer, die man überhaupt zahlt als Unternehmen?
Gewerbesteuer, aber das ist das Prinzip eben dasselbe.
Aber Gewerbesteuer, die hatten wir ja noch gar nicht. Die kommt noch sozusagen auch noch mal dazu.
Die kommt noch oben drauf, ja. Und ansonsten würde ich beim Unternehmen dann ganz schön ins Leere gucken.
Aber was unterscheidet denn jetzt bitte die Gewerbesteuer von der Körperschaftsteuer? Also ist nicht Gewerbesteuer nochmal auch in Abhängigkeit von meinen Einnahmen?
Die trifft nur bestimmte. Also die Gewerbesteuer trifft eben nur die gewerblichen Einkünfte. Wobei es die Besonderheit bei den GmbHs und Aktiengesellschaften ist, dass die allein durch die Rechtsform schon gewerbliche Einkünfte erzielen. Egal, was die dahinter machen.
Ist ja nicht jede Einnahme einer GmbH eine Gewerbeeinnahme und ein bisschen von daher Gewerbesteuer? Aber warum dann nochmal Körperschaftsteuer?
Gute Frage. Also dann würde ich aber einen riesen Unterschied haben zur Einkommensteuer. Also wenn ich dann Personen habe, die der Einkommensteuer, also natürlich Personen mit gewerblichen Einkünften, die müssen dann Einkommensteuer plus Gewerbesteuer zahlen, während die GmbH nur Gewerbesteuer zahlen müsste. Und es ist auch so, dass es im...
Ok, also verstehe, also die Körperschaftsteuer ist sozusagen gedacht als Einkommensteuer für Firmen.
Ja, so wäre der...
Und dann stellt sich aber wieder die Frage, was ist denn dann die Gewerbesteuer? Das ist dann sozusagen, wie du sagtest, die Zusatzgebühr dafür, dass man böse...
Gewerbliche Einkünfte zählen....
die Gesellschaft belastet oder was? Ja, also das ist wirklich eine zusätzliche Steuer, aber trotzdem ist auch diese Gewerbesteuer vor allem die Haupteinnahmequelle für die Kommunen. Das heißt, die Kommunen sind vor allem an Dingen interessiert, die die Gesellschaft belasten. Kann man das irgendwie so...
Ja, deswegen braucht der Staat auch viele Raucher. Also das ist... Natürlich, man will auch diejenigen haben, die Belastung darstellen, aber weil sie unter dem Strich immer noch mehr einspielen, als sie Belastung darstellen. Die Gewerbesteuer bringt ja den Gemeinden mehr, als sie der Gewerbeneutriter...
Ja, um nochmal deine These von vorhin aufzugreifen. Eigentlich könnte man das irgendwie sein lassen und sagen, alle sind irgendwie gleich. Und was die Gemeinden sozusagen jetzt da an Mehreinnahmen an der Gewerbesteuer haben versus der Einkommensteuer bzw. der Körperschaftsteuer, könnte man ja auch durch einen generellen anderen Schlüssel der Aufteilung der Einkommensteuer slash Körperschaftsteuer auch erreichen, wenn man es denn denn wollen würde.
Richtig.
Würde man das tun, hätte das dann nicht die Folge, dass auch Ärzte wieder gern gesehen sind bei den Kommunen, weil sie daran dann auch was verdienen?
Ja, wobei die Besonderheit bei der Gewerbesteuer liegt halt auch da dran und das ist mit einer Rechtfertigung den Satz der Gewerbesteuer, den bestimmt jede Gemeinde. Also das führt dazu, dass man im Berliner Umland weniger Gewerbesteuer zahlt als in Berlin.
Das heißt, das ist eigentlich wirklich mehr so ein Wettbewerbsding?
Ja, das hat auch was mit Wettbewerb der Kommunen zu tun. Wobei ich da der Meinung bin, man könnte das steuerlich, wenn man Steuerrecht wirklich vereinfachen wollte, könnte man das ja sicherlich in die Einkommenssteuer einbauen und bräuchte dafür nicht die Gewerbesteuer. Denn die Gewerbesteuer, das macht jetzt weniger Sinn, das wäre jetzt vertiefend auf die Gewerbesteuer eingehen, aber es ist nicht so, dass man die Gewerbesteuer einfach nur aus dem Gewinn rausnehmen kann, sondern man nimmt sich den Gewinn, den man für die Einkommenssteuer oder der Körperschaftssteuer zugrunde legt und fängt dann noch mal fleißig an, Sachen raufzurechnen oder runterzurechnen. Also diese Hinzu- und Abrechnung der Gewerbesteuer, die wirklich noch mal für eine, ja, es ist eine gewerbesteuerliche Gewinnermittlung, das macht das ganze Steuerermittlungsverfahren noch mal deutlich komplizierter, ohne dass es dafür...
Aber was wird, also, aber es geht doch eigentlich bei beiden oder bei all diesen Formen der Ertragssteuer, Einkommensteuer, Körperschaftsteuer, alle zielen eigentlich auf die, und die Gewerbesteuer auch, zählt alle auf den Gewinn. Gewinn. Also das, was nach Abzug aller Kosten und so weiter übrig bleibt, das wird besteuert, das heißt, die Gewerbesteuer ist dann einfach nur noch eine weitere und die ist dann aber lokal unterschiedlich.
Genau, die hat einen unterschiedlichen Satz.
Ließe sich aber auch genauso machen, indem man sagt, Einkommensteuer ist in Berlin einfach anders als in Brandenburg, weil das ist die Vorteil, was weiß ich.
Das wäre ja mal eine Idee, dass man sagt, okay, man macht einfach einen Aufschlag auf die Einkommensteuer. Also jetzt mal ins Blau hineingedacht, dass man sagt, okay, die Gemeinden haben das Recht, von 0 bis 10 Prozent auf die Einkommensteuer aufzuschlagen und dieser Anteil gehört ihnen. Also man könnte da sicherlich auch nichts machen.
Aber man merkt schon, warum das überhaupt alles so schwierig ist, an diesen ganzen Dingern überhaupt rumzuzappeln, weil man halt irgendwie mal irgendwas vereinfachen möchte. Dann schneidet man damit auch den ganzen Zopf von über Jahre hin auf fein austarierten, wenn du mir das nimmst, dann musst du mir aber das Lassnummern hin, so wie wir das jetzt glaube ich in der aktuellen Diskussion auch gerade haben, dass die Kommunen kräftig jammern über die neueste Gesetzeslage, weil es halt mal wieder bei ihnen größere Einbußen zur Folge hat als eben beim Bund. Ja, schwierig.
Das ist schwierig, da sind halt viele Interessengruppen, die da aufeinander knallen förmlich. Auch bei der Frage, wer muss eben wovon wieviel zahlen. Also das ist ja, und das hatten wir jetzt auch gerade in der politischen Diskussion, Umsatzsteuer. Ich meine, jetzt wissen wir ja endlich, was es kostet, den Umsatzsteuersatz reduzieren zu lassen.
Ach, du beziehst dich jetzt auf diese Hotelgeschichte? Warte mal, wir kommen ja gleich mal hin. Genau. Also jetzt, ich fasse noch mal zusammen, also wir hatten jetzt generell ja Top-Level irgendwie...
Besitzsteuer.
Besitzsteuer und haben über Substanzsteuern geredet. Jetzt reden wir über Ertragssteuern, dass also alles noch in diesen Besitzsteuer-Kram hineinfällt. Da drin hatten wir Einkommensteuer, wir hatten die Körperschaftsteuer. Die Erste bezieht sich eben einfach auf Personen. Andere eben auf Nicht-Personen, also gegen die Haas und die Aktiengesellschaft und so weiter. Und dann gibt es halt noch diese Gewerbesteuer, die beide irgendwie ein bisschen betrifft, außer den Piloten. Gibt es denn noch andere Ertragssteuern jetzt über diese Steuern hinaus? Nein. Okay, das heißt, die Kiste können wir sozusagen zumachen?
Haken, ja.
Haken machen. Das ist immer schön hier. Gibt es denn noch weitere Besitzsteuern über die Substanz- und Ertragssteuern hinaus?
Auch nicht? Nee. Aber die Kategorie, da wären wir schon ganz gut dabei.
Aber das ist jetzt sozusagen auch wirklich schon ein Großteil der Einnahmen des Staates, die sich eben aus diesem Modell heraus ergeben.
Aus diesem Besitzsteuermodell. Und vielleicht, um da ein bisschen nochmal an dem Besitzsteuern festzubleiben, was auch in der politischen Diskussion, wo so die wirklichen Schwierigkeiten ablaufen, wie du auch schon sagtest, wir nehmen eben so das, was du alles kriegst, dann darfst du davon abziehen, was du dafür herausgegeben hast. Das System haben wir in den verschiedenen Arten. Das haben wir bei den unselbstständigen Einkünften, also bei den Arbeitnehmern. Deswegen dürfen die auch ihren Fahrten, wohnen Arbeit, oder wenn sie Kleidung ausgeben müssen für ihren Beruf oder sowas, dürfen sie auch absetzen, weil das ist ja etwas, das abgeht von dem, was sie als Arbeitslohn kriegen. Das selbe Problem trifft erst recht die gewerblichen und selbstständigen Einkünfte. Was kann man davon absetzen? Und das ist der Teil, der uns die wirklichen Probleme bereitet. Du hast ja von schon gelacht, dass ich gesagt hab, die Zahl hinten zu verändern, das ist für uns technisch nicht das Problem. Das eigentliche Problem, das wir haben, ist, wie viel ist zu besteuern? Also du erzielst Einnahmen, ich als Rechtsanwalt, erziele Einnahmen beispielsweise aus meinem Honorar. Gehe jetzt mit meinem Mandanten essen. Wie viel darf ich dann davon abziehen? Weil ich gehe ja selbst auch für mich, also ich esse ja auch mit, da sparen wir beim Mittagessen, was uns eigentlich privat wäre. Dort haben wir dann auch eine Sonderregelung, die sagt, okay, dann darfst du davon nur 70 Prozent abziehen. Aber da gibt es eben viele Punkte. Und da liegt ja eigentlich ein Krux, wie viel darf ich besteuern? Nachher zu sagen, wenn ich diese Zahl erstmal habe, zu sagen, okay, ich habe 100.000 Umsatz gemacht, ich habe 50.000 Ausgaben gehabt, ich habe also einen Gewinn von 50.000, darauf dann eine Zahl zu schlagen, das ist eine relativ einfache Geschichte. Ob diese Zahl dann sich in einer Progression widerspiegelt, dann gucke ich halt an die Tabelle nach, das ist irgendwie nicht schwierig. Oder ob diese Zahl sich mal ändert, dann nehme ich mir eben eine neue Tabelle. Da ist nicht das Problem. Also jedenfalls nicht für die Frage Steuervereinfachung. Das ist etwas, wo keiner mit rumquält, sondern die Frage, wieviel darf ich abschreiben? Diese ganzen Themenkomplexe, die machen das Steuerrecht brutal schwer. Und gerade bei den GmbHs, die müssen auch bilanzieren. Also dort ist die Gewinnermittlung nichts, was man eben so wegmacht. Da liegt die eigentliche Krux, da liegt auch die eigentliche Arbeit in der Steuerberatung, zu ermitteln, wie hoch ist das zu versteuernde Einkommen.
Das hast du schon ein paar Mal erwähnt, das ist das Modell der Progression, was ja im Prinzip heißt, es gibt nicht einen festen Steuersatz, sondern der Steuersatz ändert sich mit dem zu besteuernden Betrag, den man ermittelt hat. Das heißt, erst ermittelt man den, und dann, wie du es schön sagst, guckt man der Tabelle nach, da gibt es halt irgendwie so eine Kurve, beziehungsweise so eine, ja, immer noch weiter umsteigende Linie. Was ist jetzt sozusagen die Argumentation für eine Progression? Also was drückt sich da drin aus in diesem variablen Steuersatz?
Dieser variable Steuersatz, der hat erstmal so einen sogenannten Grundfreibetrag, also da besteuere ich gar nichts. Das ist so mein Existenzminimum, das bin ich besteuert. Und danach besteuere ich den Anteil, der da drüber liegt. Das fängt dann mit 14% an. Und ich steige das an, weil ich dann sage, dass jemand, der mehr verdient, kann nicht nur prozentual mehr geben, sondern er kann auch im Verhältnis tatsächlich mehr geben. Es fällt eben jemand, um es mal ganz krassen Zahlen zu bringen. Jemand, der 50.000 im Jahr hat, der braucht eben nicht nur 30%, also die Zahlen sind jetzt wirklich aus der Luft gegriffen, der braucht eben nicht nur 30% im Jahr Einkommensteuerzahlen. Im Vergleich zu jemandem, der eine Million verdient, für den ist auch 50% immer noch okay, weil bei dem bleibt immer noch eine Menge übrig. Deswegen sagt man, da kann der Ersatz auch problemlos ansteigen. Das ist der Nachteil. Ich kann nicht genau sagen, wenn du mir zuwürfst, du hast dieses Jahr eine Fantasie Millionen verdient, kann ich dir nicht einfach mal Schnipp sagen, was du verdient hast, sondern entweder ich brauche eine Tabelle oder du musst dann mal hier kurz an den Rechner ran, um drauf zu rechnen.
Das heißt, ok, jetzt hast du ja auch wieder ein paar andere Begriffe, die ja auch, sagen wir mal, täglich, wo man sich der täglichen Begegnung in der Nachrichtenlage immer wieder erfreuen kann, genannt. Sollte man vielleicht nochmal aufgreifen, also sowas wie Grundfrei-Betrag hat man ja an vielen Ebenen. Und was hier auch noch mit reinfällt, hast du jetzt noch nicht gesagt, ist wahrscheinlich auch dieser Spitzensteuersatz. Wie ist denn das derzeit? Also jetzt nochmal so ein Modell zu haben. Also die Einkommenssteuer?
Also aktuell, wenn ich jetzt Richtung Koffer bei 14% los. Und endet bei 47%. Und dann müsste man gleich in dem Atemzug noch als Zuschlagssteuer den Solidaritätszuschlag oben draufschlagen.
Hm, der Solidaritätszuschlag.
Das ist ja auch so ein ganz tolles Thema.
Der ist eigentlich Teil dieser Einkommenssteuer?
Ja, das ist eine sogenannte Zuschlagssteuer.
Bezieht sich das nur auf die Einkommenssteuer?
Und auf die Körperschaftssteuer.
Also Firmen wie auch Personen zahlen extra für die deutsche Einheit. Und das heißt, sie zahlen, also Solidaritätszuschlag heißt, der Steuersatz wird noch erhöht.
Nee, man zahlt auf die Einkommenssteuer nochmal 5,5% Solidaritätszuschlag.
Also von dem, was man an Steuern zahlt?
Da drauf dann nochmal 5,5% Solidaritätszuschlag.
Das heißt sozusagen eine gleichmäßige Anhebung aller Steuersätze im Prinzip?
Das macht das Rechnen natürlich wieder ein Stück einfacher. Also das ist eben auch so was, wo ich mir sage, wir haben das Thema ja jetzt auch, ist ja überhaupt verfassungsgemäß, weil der Solidaritätszuschlag läuft ja immer noch weiter. Auch so was, wo ich mir denke, naja, das könnte man ja auch viel einfacher machen. Sollen wir doch die Einkommenssteuer und Körperschaftssteuer einfach mal um zwei, drei, vier Prozent auch immer anheben, sodass das Finanzierungsvolumen, was man ja mehr oder minder unstreitig einfach mal braucht, dass das gleich bleibt, könnt ihr sagen, statt Eingangssteuersatz 14 Prozent, gehe ich auf 18 Prozent und statt einen Spitzensteuersatz von 47, gehe ich eben auf 52.
Was das ja de facto auch wahrscheinlich bedeutet, also die Zahlen jetzt, die Glaubensregeln, ne?
Ja, also die Zahlen jetzt sich festgenagelt, und schafft dafür den Solidaritätszuschlag ab, um diese zusätzliche Rechnerei einfach zu ersparen. Aber da kann man sich irgendwie nicht so richtig von trennen. Ich vermute mal, dass man Angst hat, dass es politisch schwerer zu verkaufen wäre, weil am Ende der Strecke in der Bildsaturnur noch übrig bliebe, die Steuer wird erhöht.
Genau, so ist es ja nur ein Zuschlag.
So ist es nur ein Zuschlag, und der ist schon da.
Das ist überhaupt extrem kreativ, das ganze Steuerbusiness, was so Begriffe betrifft, ne? Also da gibt es irgendwie Zuschläge, also Steuern natürlich erstmal, da gibt es Zuschläge, da gibt es Abgaben, oder fällt das nicht wirklich ins Steuerrecht?
Steuern sind Abgaben. Was man davon trennen kann, sind Bühren und Beiträge. Das sind dann so die Teile, wo ich dann eine Gegenleistung für habe, oder zumindest mal die Möglichkeit habe, eine Gegenleistung in Anspruch zu nehmen. Also so die Schwimmbad-Benutzung, einen öffentlich-rechtlichen Schwimmbad, oder das Ausstellen eines Personalausweises, oder unser sicherlich alles Lieblingsthema, die GEZ. Dort zahle ich auch für die Möglichkeit der Nutzung öffentlich-rechtlicher Fernsehprogramme. Und das sind eben keine Steuern, weil dort habe ich eine individualisierbare Gegenleistung, oder jedenfalls die Möglichkeit, die individualisierbare Gegenleistung, das habe ich bei Steuern grundsätzlich nicht. Bei Steuern zahle ich einen großen Topf, ohne dass ich sagen kann, und dafür steht mir jetzt so das Stück Straße zu. Und ich kann halt auch diesen Topf nicht individualisiert steuern. Also die Idee, die denn schon einige hatten, naja, ich bin ja bereit, Steuern zu zahlen, aber ich möchte nicht, dass meine Einnahmen für militär genutzt werden. Das geht halt nicht. Das ist ein großer Topf, wo alles reinkommt, und dann wird alles rausgenommen. Also ich glaube, das wäre auch verwaltungstechnisch schlichtweg unlösbares Problem.
Bleiben wir trotzdem noch mal bei den Steuern als solche. Also wir haben jetzt auch diesen Ertragssteuertopf haben wir jetzt auch wirklich zu, und damit haben wir auch einen Besitzsteuertopf zu. Neben den Besitzsteuern, vor allem also Einkommensteuer und Körperschaftsteuer, die so zum Großteil der Steuereinnahmen des Staates beitragen, gibt es dann noch die Verkehrssteuer.
Ja, und bei der Verkehrssteuer so ganz voran die sogenannte Umsatzsteuer.
Aber es gibt auch noch andere.
Es gibt dann noch die Verbrauchsteuern.
Die fallen auch unter Verkehrssteuern.
Nee, das ist so ein eigener Top-Level.
Nee, ich meinte jetzt konkret so, Verkehrssteuern ist Umsatzsteuer.
Eine der Verkehrssteuerarten ist die Umsatzsteuer.
Ja, und was das eine andere Verkehrssteuer hat?
Grunderwerbsteuer und die Versicherungssteuer fehlen da noch drunter.
Grunderwerbssteuer, wir haben ja noch nie gehört.
Dann hast du noch nie eine Wohnung oder ein Haus verkauft? Da fällt nämlich jedes Mal die Grunderwerbsteuer an. Also wenn du ein Haus kaufst, musst du da drauf Grunderwerbsteuer zahlen.
Verstehe.
Auf den Kaufpreis 3,5 bis 4,5 Prozent.
Okay, aber die Versicherungssteuer, okay klar, das kennt man, das ist 7 Prozent glaube ich, die man bei einer Versicherung zahlt, Versicherungssteuer, wo aber dann keine Mehrwertsteuer ist.
Genau, dafür ist keine Umsatzsteuer.
Die heißt einfach nur anders, damit man einen anderen Prozentsatz haben kann.
Nee, die heißt auch deshalb anders, weil ich sie nicht als Vorsteuer ziehen kann. Da müssen wir die Umsatzsteuer etwas einsteigen.
Genau, jetzt kommen wir nämlich gleich in ein tolles Thema. Okay, also der Katalog, den wir aufgemacht haben, ist Verkehrssteuer. Es gibt da mehrere, aber vor allem ist die Verkehrssteuer diese Umsatzsteuer. Und jetzt kommen wir nämlich schon mal genau zu so einem Punkt, Vorsteuer ist auch noch so ein Begriff. Mehrwertsteuer sagt man, Umsatzsteuer sagt man, alles irgendwie dasselbe, aber dann doch nicht. Das musst du jetzt mal aufklären.
Das wäre eine echte Leistung dieses Podcasts. Also der Begriff Umsatzsteuer, Mehrwertsteuer wird zwar pseudonym verwendet, man müsste aber inzwischen richtigerweise eben nur noch von der Umsatzsteuer sprechen, weil das deutsche Recht kennt nur das Umsatzsteuergesetz. Den Begriff Mehrwertsteuer, den gibt es nur noch auf europäischer Ebene, denn dort gibt es die sogenannten Mehrwertsteuerrichtlinien. Aber auf unseren Rechnungen unten müsste UST draufstehen und nicht MFST.
Das heißt, wenn man da seine Rechnungen draufschreibt, plus Mehrwertsteuer, weil man das so meint, dass es so ist, genau genommen ist es falsch.
Ja, es ist eben nicht wirklich falsch.
Also keiner beschwert sich.
Technisch müsste man sagen, es heißt eben Umsatzsteuer. Aber man findet auch fertige Quittungsblöcke von größeren Herstellern, die die Dinger fertig ausliefern, mit MWST.
Wahrscheinlich weil die Kunden sie wieder zurückbringen, wenn da noch eine Rundung draufsteht.
Genau, mein Steuerbrat hat gesagt, da muss die Rundung wieder satt stehen. Mir krisselt es immer so ein bisschen am Fußnägel, wenn ich das lese, aber es ist natürlich nicht wirklich falsch. Aber technisch richtig ist Umsatzsteuer. Wir haben ein Umsatzsteuergesetz und kein Mehrwertsteuergesetz. Und im Umsatzsteuergesetz gibt es eben auch nur den Begriff Umsatzsteuer und noch den Begriff Vorsteuer. Das ist noch mal so ein eigenes Teil. Also das ist erstmal der Unterschied zwischen Mehrwertsteuer und Umsatzsteuer.
Was hieß es irgendwann mal Mehrwertsteuer? Ich meine, wie kommt man überhaupt darauf, dass es Mehrwertsteuer heißen könnte, wenn es eigentlich Umsatzsteuer heißt?
Weil wir de facto den Mehrwert besteuern. Also da müssen wir vielleicht mal ein bisschen in die Geschichte der Umsatzsteuer zurückgreifen. Früher, als noch alles besser war, damals war es wirklich nicht besser. Es war wenigstens noch alles aus Holz. Bis 1967 waren dann die Reformen. Es war so, dass man immer, wenn man etwas verkauft hat, also ähnlich wie die amerikanischen Sale Taxes, glaube ich, die haben das immer noch so, hat man, wenn man die Ware für 100 Euro verkauft, musste man da drauf einen, war relativ niedrig, 4% Mehrwertsteuer abführen. Ich habe deswegen für 104 Euro verkauft und musste 4 Euro an den Start abführen. 104 habe ich dann vom Käufer bekommen. Wenn der Käufer ein Händler war, also nehmen wir an, die Fabrik verkauft das für 104 Euro, 4 Euro führt sie ans Finanzamt ab und der kriegt das für 104 Euro. Der verkauft das jetzt, Willis wird 200 weiterverkaufen, dann hat man 208 Euro genommen. 8 Euro hat er ins Finanzamt weiter abgeführt und die 200 Euro hat er bekommen. Also hat er insgesamt 208 bekommen, 8 muss er abführen. Wenn der Großhändler es dann an den Tante-Emma-Markt verkauft hat und die hat es für 400 weiterverkaufen wollen, musste sie 416 nehmen, 16 hat sie ins Finanzamt abgeführt, da wird schon deutlich, umso länger diese Kette wird, umso höher wird das, was an Steuern eingenommen wird. Das hat einen Nachteil gehabt, weil der Tante-Emma-Markt, der viel weiter unten in der Kette stand, als ein Großhändler, der vielleicht noch so einen Verkauf auch an den Einzelhandel hat, der also viel weniger Lieferstationen zwischendrin hat, der muss entsprechend weniger zahlen. Das empfand man mit als unbefriedigend, aber wie gesagt, der Steuersatz war damals auch deutlich geringer.
Warte mal, wer muss weniger an wen zahlen? Der Emmerladen muss weniger an wen zahlen?
Nee, der Emmerladen, also wenn ich das wirklich so vom Fabrik-Großhandel, kleinerer Großhandel, Tante Emmerladen habe, dann ist die Steuerbelastung viel höher.
Von wem?
Vom Endverbraucher, ja. Das bedeutet aber auch, dass damit der Tante Emmerladen wettbewerbs-, auf gleicher Wettbewerb preislich stehen kann, kann er viel weniger einnehmen, weil er steuerlich ist.
Er muss sozusagen seine Preise senken.
Um die Mehrbelastung an Steuern wieder wegzumachen im Vergleich zu demjenigen, der direkt ab Fabrik verkauft. Und das ist ja erstmal unbefriedigend, dass ich sage, umso mehr Stufen ich dazwischen habe, umso höher wird die Steuer. Das war ein Grund. Der zweite war dann die Harmonisierung der Umsatzsteuer in der europäischen Gemeinschaft. Da hat man dieses System aufgegeben. Jetzt haben wir, das hört sich irgendwie kompliziert an, Allphasen-Netto-Umsatzsteuer mit Vorsteuerabzug. Nochmal? Allphasen-Netto-Umsatzbesteuerung mit Vorsteuerabzug. Das ist das System, das wir jetzt haben. Wir besteuern auch jetzt jede Phase. Allphasen-Netto-Umsatzbesteuerung mit Vorsteuerabzug. Das führt dazu, ich besteuere immer auf den Netto-Wert. Eben die 19%. Insofern das System bleibt scheinbar erst mal dasselbe. Ich guck mir an, wie viel du fast verkaufst und hau da 19% drauf. Oder Steuersatz X hau ich dann da drauf. Aber die Besonderheit jetzt ist, wenn ich es als Unternehmer eingekauft habe, dann kann ich mir die Umsatzsteuer, die mein Vorverkäufer ans Finanzamt zahlt, also beispielsweise die Fabrik, verkauft es mir für 100 Euro. 19% Umsatzsteuer gehen ans Finanzamt. Ich bin der Zwischenhändler. Ich hole mir die 19 Euro, die der ans Finanzamt gezahlt hat. Die hole ich mir vom Finanzamt wieder. Wenn ich es dann für 200 verkaufe, muss ich zwar dort auf die 200 Euro 19% draufschlagen und muss die ans Finanzamt abführen. Habe aber die Vorsteuer, da kommt dieser Begriff, was der vorher gezahlt hat, die Vorsteuern wiedergeholt. Sodass unterm Strich eine erheblich niedrigere Belastung stattfindet. Das macht natürlich das System wesentlich komplizierter und macht das auch missbrauchsanfälliger. Aber es sorgt dafür, dass die Länge der Lieferkette sich nicht direkt auf die Steuer auswirkt.
Wann muss man diesen Begriff nutzen, Vorsteuer? Das bezieht sich jetzt sozusagen nur auf dieses...
Das ist praktisch die Steuer. Wenn ich als Unternehmer, bin als Anwalt auch umsatzsteuerlich ein Unternehmer, wenn ich Sachen einkaufe, beispielsweise Bücher oder Papier, muss ich dafür auch Umsatzsteuer mit auf den Tresen legen. Ich lege eigentlich zwei Beträge auf den Tresen. Ich lege einmal das, was der Verkäufer bekommt, und einmal, was das Finanzamt bekommt, auf den Tresen. Und er verwaltet es treuhänderisch und führt das ans Finanzamt ab. Und dieses Geld kriege ich vom Finanzamt wieder. Das ist die Vorsteuer. Alles das, was ich im Rahmen meines Unternehmens ausgebe, und in der Umsatzsteuer enthalten ist.
Von mir bezahlte Umsatzsteuer heißt Vorsteuer, solange ich jemand bin, der sie auch wieder kriegt.
Beziehungsweise der, welcher zahlen muss. Also wenn ich auf meine Leistungen Umsatzsteuer zahlen muss, aufschlagen muss, dann kriege ich sie auch wieder.
Und wann muss ich welche aufschlagen?
Wenn ich Unternehmer bin und nicht unter die Kleinunternehmerregelung falle, bzw. darauf nicht verzichtet habe.
Das hat aber nichts wieder mit diesen Berufsgruppen und den Katalogen zu tun?
Nein, also die Umsatzsteuer ist tatsächlich rechtsformneutral. Also das ist völlig egal, ob ich Einzelunternehmer, ob ich Handwerker, Rechtsanwalt oder GmbH bin. Dort sind vor dem Gesetz alle gleich. Und also auch die GBR.
Okay, aber die kleinen Unternehmer müssen das nicht machen. Was ist ein Kleinunternehmer?
Die Kleinunternehmer, das sind so Umsatzgrößen. Also man sagt so bis, wenn ich Rechnungen habe, 17.000 Umsatz im Jahr. Dort kann ich sagen, ich will keine Umsatzsteuer auf meine Rechnung ausweisen. Das hat für mich den Vorteil, ich brauche nicht diese meldungen machen, die monatlichen. In den ersten zwei Jahren muss ich ja monatlich sogar Vorstellungen anmelden.
Und ich kann niedrigere Preise machen?
Die niedrigeren Preise sind dann interessant, wenn ich als Kunde einen Verbraucher habe. Wenn ich ein Unternehmer habe, dem ist es egal, weil da kriegt er sowieso wieder. Ich schwache mir schlichtweg Verwaltungsarbeit auch. Habe dafür den Nachteil, ich kriege natürlich, denn das ist ja dann nur systemkonform, ich kriege dann natürlich auch die Vorsteuer nicht wieder.
Das heißt, wenn ich mir Büroausstattung usw. kaufe, muss ich dann eben auch die Mehrwertsteuer zahlen.
Genau.
Das heißt, unterm Strich ist man eigentlich besser dran, wenn man vorsteuerabzugsberechtigt ist.
Das kommt darauf an, wie hoch die Ausgaben sind, die man hat und wie man so als Kunden hat. Also gerade wenn ich als Kunde einen Unternehmer oder überwiegend Unternehmer habe, die die Vorsteuer ziehen können, dann macht es keinen Sinn. Weil wenn ich mit dem 100 Euro ausmache, ist es dem egal, ob ich da Umsatzsteuer draufschlage nochmal und 119 nehme oder nicht. Dann kriegst du eh wieder. Wenn ich natürlich Verbraucher habe, also nicht Unternehmer, denen ist das nicht egal.
Aber es lohnt sich aber sozusagen vor allem dann, wenn ich selber nicht viel Umsatzsteuer zahlen muss, um meinen Betrieb aufrechtzuhalten.
Nur dann darf ich es auch. Das ist die Kleinunternehmer-Regelung. Das soll für die kleinen Unternehmer eine Vereinfachung darstellen. Bloß weil jemand mal drei Rechnungen im Jahr schreibt, will man den ganzen Verwaltungsaufwand nicht aufhalten. Aber er kann darauf verzichten.
Jetzt gibt es bei der Umsatzsteuer, jetzt bleibe ich mal hier korrekt in den Terminologien, naja, haben wir da was gelassen. Zwei Sätze, die ermäßigte und die nicht ermäßigte. Gibt es noch eine andere? Nein.
Es gibt da noch die steuerfreien, also guter Gesetzgeber.
Okay, also es gibt im Prinzip drei Sätze. Sätze 07 und 19. Und 7% ist für, tja, wofür eigentlich?
Grundnahrungsmittel fallen darunter.
Das heißt, hier ist das Ziel einer niedrigen Mehrwertschar, Entsatzsteuer ist, dass es für den Endverbraucher günstiger wird, der Endpreis. Das ist sozusagen eine soziale Komponente.
Nur der Endverbraucher zahlt ja defakte die Umsatzsteuer. Und da ist eine soziale Komponente dahinter. Das sieht man eben in der Auswahl. Das sind die Grundnahrungsmittel. Da gibt es einen ganzen Katalog, den keiner durchsieht. Bücher fallen darunter, weil der Mensch lebt nicht nur vom Boot allein. Da fallen teilweise künstlerische Aufführungen. Darunter. Reiseleistungen bis 50 Kilometer, Taxis, die haben normalerweise 7 Prozent. Bei den Umsatzsteuerbefreiten sieht man es teilweise auch. Ärztliche Leistungen fallen überwiegend zu Umsatzsteuerbefreiten. Das ist zwar umsatzsteuerbar, sprich eigentlich unterliegen sie. Das sind die Unternehmer. Aber da gibt es eine Norm, die sagt, dafür wollen wir keine Umsatzsteuer haben. Und dann gibt es den normalen Satz und das sind dann eben die 19 Prozent.
Jetzt muss ich mich über dieses Warum fragen. Warum gibt es diese Steuer überhaupt? Man könnte ja auch sagen, gut, die Firmen wirtschaften, sie nehmen irgendwie Dinge ein und am Ende gucken wir mal, was sie so gewonnen haben und das ist so ihre eigentliche Wertschöpfung offensichtlich. Und da haben wir dann ja auch unsere Instrumente, sprich Körperschaftssteuer, Einkommensteuer, je nachdem wie Unternehmen oder Einzelkämpfer da aufgestellt ist. Und wenn ihr irgendwie was erzeugt habt, so dann, also wenn ihr sozusagen einen Gewinn erzielt habt, wie man so schön sagt, dann schöpfen wir halt dann ab und umso mehr ihr da erzielt, umso mehr schöpfen wir auch ab, die Progressionsgeschichte. Und gut ist, warum braucht man eine Umsatzsteuer? Wie kam man überhaupt auf die Idee? Was ist sozusagen der Sinn der ganzen Sache? Wozu?
Es gibt also erstmal wie gesagt Finanzierung natürlich. Also irgendwie muss halt das Geld in die Staatskasse rein.
Ja gut, aber dann könnte man ja auch sagen, man nimmt einfach mehr von den Einnahmen.
Die Umsatzsteuer hat zwei Ansatzpunkte. Das eine ist Bequemlichkeit der Besteuerung. Sprich, der Bürger kriegt es fast nicht mit. Das ist sogenannte indirekte Steuer. Denn ich muss ja nicht selbst wirklich abführen.
Man macht das, weil es keiner merkt.
Ja, genau. Das ist ein nicht zu verachtender Punkt. Das ist eine ganz tolle Steuer, weil die kriege ich nicht wirklich mit. Also die kriege ich dann mit, wenn ich das mal wirklich zusammenrechne, was ich an Umsatzsteuer zahle. Aber eigentlich kriege ich die nicht mit. Die läuft halt so beim Ladentisch drüber und keiner weiß es so richtig. Der zweite Grund ist, ich besteuere damit den Konsum. Umso mehr ich konsumiere, umso mehr zahle ich auch. Da fangen aber eben auch die Probleme an. Das macht das große Problem der Umsatzsteuer. Denn der Hartz IV-Empfänger, der hat eine Konsumquote von Hartz IV, der gibt eigentlich alles Geld, was er bekommt, gibt auch aus. Oder jemand im Niedriglohnsektor. Brauchen wir jetzt mal nicht neue, die auf staatliche Transferlastung angewiesen sind. Sondern jemand, der wenig verdient, der gibt fast alles, was er hat aus. Das bedeutet sein...
Ja, aber nicht alles, was er ausgibt, ist ja auch umsatzsteuerbehaft.
Das ist richtig.
Miete?
Miete ist im Regelfall nicht umsatzsteuerbelastet. Aber der Rest dürfte überwiegend umsatzsteuerbelastet sein.
Also Essen, Trinken...
Essen, Trinken, Kleidung, Bücher...
Bildzeitung kaufen.
Bildzeitung kaufen, Kino kaufen, Spielzeug kaufen, Babykleidung kaufen, das ist alles umsatzsteuerbelastet. Also der wird schon den überwiegenden Teil an Umsatzsteuer auch wieder lassen. Andere Leute? Wer sehr viel verdient und eben nicht alles ausgibt, sondern es sich leisten kann auch zu sparen, der verkonsumiert eben auch nicht alles an Geld. Und der zahlt im Verhältnis gesehen dadurch weniger Umsatzsteuer. Und ich kann auch keine sozialen, also jedenfalls in derzeitigen, man könnte man machen, aber macht man der Fakte nicht, die Frage, was ich genau damit besteuere. Also jemand, der viele Kinder hat, der kauft eben viele Kinderkleidung, die wird genauso belastet wie der Pelzmantel. Also der Pelzmantel ist teurer, dadurch zahle ich mehr, aber der Satz ist derselbe. Und entweder ich lasse es relativ schlicht, so wie wir es jetzt haben, oder ich fange an, dort wirklich das Fass aufzumachen und zu sagen, was will ich jetzt eigentlich gefördert haben oder nicht. Und dadurch nehme ich die Umsatzsteuer, mache ich sie relativ schlicht, wobei, davon muss man sich verabschieden, die Umsatzsteuer sind relativ komplizierte Steuer in ihrer Handhabung. Jedenfalls, wenn es dann in die Problembereiche reingeht. Aber das Grundprinzip so bleibt relativ schlicht. Wenn ich sie sozial machen wollte, sofern es überhaupt geht, würde sie ausufernkompliziert. Das will man nicht. Gerade weil man auch nicht will, dass man sie nicht mehr drossig mitkriegt.
Wenn man sie sozial machen wollen würde, dann würde sie ausufern?
Ja, sofern es überhaupt ginge. Weil ich dann überlegen müsste, wie ist es mit verschiedenen Steuersätzen? Was mache ich mit Babykleidung? Sollte ich vielleicht auch in den Katalog rein mit 7 %? Oder brauche ich vielleicht noch einen Katalog, wo ich sage, der hängt mal irgendwo dazwischen? Oder habe ich einen Lobby, der meine Spende lässt?
Ich forsche immer noch ein bisschen nach diesem eigentlichen Argument, warum überhaupt an der Umsatzbildung, also an dieser Weiterverkaufskette überhaupt eine Steuer dranhängt. Ich meine nur das Argument mit, da merkt es keiner. Das ist ja dann aber schon ein modernes Raubrittertum. Ich meine, merkt keiner, kann man auch anders erzielen.
Aber das ist ja genau der entscheidende Punkt. Dann zahlt halt jeder mal. Hier zahlt derjenige, der es wirklich zahlt, zahlt es eben nicht. Weil abführend ans Finanzamt tut es der Verkäufer. Der Kunde führt es nicht ans Finanzamt ab, der kriegt es nicht mit. Der sagt einfach, ich gehe in den Laden und bezahle ja zu 120 Euro für irgendwas.
Ja gut, das nehme ich jetzt einfach zur Kenntnis, dass es natürlich schwer festzustellen ist. Trotzdem wissen wir es ja alle, dass es stattfindet. Ich denke, es hat sich auch weitgehend rumgesprochen, dass es so der Endverbraucher ist, der letzten Endes diesen Betrag errichtet. Und dass alle Leute in dieser Kette das nicht haben. Trotzdem spricht man ja auch von einer Mehrwertkette. Das heißt, die Idee ist ja, dass sozusagen dadurch, dass es von einer Hand zur anderen geht, kommt ja immer irgendein Wert noch hinzu. Sei es, dass die Ware näher zu mir kommt, oder dass sie in sonst irgendeiner Form ja auch noch veredelt wird. Das ist ja nicht so, dass die Ware immer nur in derselben Form weitergegeben wird, sondern, was weiß ich, vielleicht verpackt angereichert, mit anderen Sachen kombiniert oder sonst wie aufgehübscht oder keine Ahnung. Und dafür bin ich dann eben auch bereit, einen Mehrpreis zu zahlen im Verhältnis zu der Kette davor. Trotzdem weiß ich jetzt noch nicht so ganz genau, was die eigentliche Theorie dahinter ist, dass ich das sozusagen auch akzeptieren soll. Also was ist so gut daran, dass diese Umsatzkette besteuert wird? Wäre die Welt eine schlechtere Welt, wenn das von morgen nicht mehr stattfinden würde? Was wäre der Effekt?
Der Effekt wäre, dass ich die Frage, wie hoch meine Konsumquote ist, also wie viel von meinem zur Verfügung stehenden Einkommen ich tatsächlich dann auch verkonsumiere, dass ich das gerade nicht noch steuerlich erfassen würde. Das wäre der Effekt. Wir hatten im Vorgespräch ja kurz das Thema Grundeinkommen, wo gesagt wurde, ich will eigentlich nur noch besteuern, oder da will ich den Schwerpunkt dran festmachen, was die Leute verkonsumieren, was der Steuerbürger verkonsumiert. Genau das mache ich ja mit der Umsatzsteuer. Umso mehr ich verkonsumiere, umso mehr zahle ich auch. Das ist einfach mal ein zusätzlicher Punkt, an dem ich es festmachen kann. Ich glaube, der entscheidende Ausgangspunkt ist, dass ich sage, ich habe nicht einen zentralen Punkt, woran ich es festmache, wie ich meine Steuer bemesse, sondern es gibt verschiedene Möglichkeiten und ich nutze sie und versuche dadurch, das etwas breiter zu streuen.
Ja gut, aber ich versuche immer noch, mich einfach zu nähern, wenn ich so der Staat wäre, und ich müsste auch meinen Bürgern gegenüber, das soll ja auch mal vorkommen, auch mal legitimieren, was ich eigentlich tue, abgesehen davon, dass der Bürger natürlich der Staat ist und so. Aber man muss das ja auch alles mal intellektuell zusammengefegt bekommen. Warum tue ich das halt eigentlich? Warum lasse ich das nicht morgen einfach bleiben? Es muss ja irgendwie einen guten Grund geben.
Wie gesagt, der Hauptgrund, den darf man halt nie vergessen. Der Staat braucht Geld.
Ja gut, klar, klar, natürlich.
Irgendwie muss er rankommen.
Irgendwie muss er rankommen, aber ihr könnt ja auch eine andere Methode wählen. Warum wird sozusagen diese Schöpfungskette explizit noch mal mit einem Steuersatz belegt? Und das Einzige, was mir halt so jetzt ist, so nach dem Motto, wer sich es leisten kann, etwas zu konsumieren, ist sozusagen auch angehalten, für diesen Luxus zu zahlen. Mal kurz gesagt.
Die Frage...
Wir platzten schon ein bisschen an diese Grundeinkommensdiskussion. Die wollte ich jetzt noch nicht unbedingt aus der Kiste holen, aber so verstehe ich das. Also das ist sozusagen... Klar, jetzt kann man sagen, Essen kaufen und so weiter, das kann ja wohl kein Luxus sein. Kann man natürlich auf der anderen Seite auch sagen, wenn halt das Minimum an der Stelle dann auch abgedeckt ist durch sonstige soziale Zuwendungen, kann es mir ja eigentlich auch egal sein. Da findet eine Umverteilung statt. Genau, es ist so eine schwere Diskussion, ist die Umsatzsteuer jetzt irgendwie eigentlich eine faire Steuer oder ist sie eine unfaire Steuer?
Das ist ja das, was ich versucht habe zu sagen. Das ist das Problem der Umsatzsteuer, dass sie keine ernstnehmende soziale Komponente enthält. Der Vorteil der Umsatzsteuer, sie ist indirekt, es kriegt sie keiner mit. Der Nachteil der Umsatzsteuer, sie enthält durch das System schon keine ernstnehmenden sozialen Komponenten. Und dass ich überhaupt so etwas wie die Umsatzsteuer, also eine Verkehrssteuer neben den Besitzsteuern laufen habe, ist nur damit zu erklären, ich sage, ich habe verschiedene... Also ich muss mich ja irgendwie mal dem Thema nähern, wo ziehe ich jetzt dem Staat das Geld aus der Tasche, äh dem Bürger das Geld aus der Tasche, damit der Staat finanziert wird. Und statt zu sagen, ich nehme von den verschiedenen Möglichkeiten, die ich habe, nehme ich nur einen Punkt raus, nehme ich eben wirklich das potpourrieren Möglichkeiten mit, was sich mir da bietet. Und das tue ich de facto. Also ich greife ja so alle möglichen Vorgänge ab. Das sehen wir ja auch. Du sprachst ja vorhin schon mal kurz an, dann wird mir das Geld geschenkt, der Erbschaften schenken Steuer, also auch dort greife ich dazu.
Ich meine, ich finde es immer, für mein Gefühl ist sozusagen, Steuern, Erhebung muss immer an der Stelle erfolgen, wo halt jemand einen Vorteil nutzt sozusagen. Und von diesem Vorteil, den er hat, muss er der Gemeinschaft wieder was geben. Das wäre jetzt so mein simplizistischer Ansatz an der Stelle. Und das versuche ich jetzt immer bei jeder Steuer so ein bisschen mitzudenken, was ist denn da der Vorteil? Und ich könnte das jetzt bei der Umsatzsteuer argumentieren, okay klar, der Vorteil ist überhaupt, konsumieren zu können.
Das ist jemand, der sich offensichtlich leisten kann.
Ja, weil man nimmt ja auch den puren Mehrwert entgegen. Andere tun was für mich. Und ich bezahle das halt mit meinem Vermögen. Das ist ja ein sehr entspannter Vorgang. Keiner von uns muss wirklich noch die Kartoffeln selber anpflanzen, sondern man geht halt einfach in den Supermarkt und da liegen sie einfach so rum, schön im Netz drum herum, dass man sie auch noch leicht nach Hause tragen kann. Alles ist wunderbar, schöne neue Welt. Und das ist sozusagen jetzt so der Luxus, den ich mir einfach leisten kann, aus meinem Vermögen heraus. Auf welchem Wege ich mir das auch immer erarbeitet habe. Also auch wenn ich reich bin, zahle ich das ja auch. Weil du hast vorhin so gesagt, ich könnte es ja auch sparen. Jetzt ist die Frage, ist das was Schlechtes irgendwie zu sparen?
Das muss nicht schlechtes sein. Aber das muss ich mir auch erstmal leisten können. Sparen können muss man sich leisten können.
Im Jahr der Krise hat man sich ja sehr gefreut, dass die Leute auch mal gespart haben. Was ja am letzten Ende bedeutet, dass man damit Geld im System belässt, mit dem Kredite gegeben werden kann. Ich will jetzt nicht die komplette Wirtschaftssendung machen, aber nur, um das mal ein bisschen nachzuvollziehen. Ist das was Schlechtes?
Nein, nicht unbedingt, aber für die Frage ist diese Besteuerung gerecht. Da muss ich mir die Frage stellen, wer kann denn überhaupt es sich leisten, sich von dieser Steuer herauszunehmen? Wenn jemand sagt, ich hab keine Lust, um das Steuer zu zahlen, stellt sich die Frage, muss ich einfach nur nicht konsumieren. Das muss ich mir aber erst mal und spare mehr.
Konsumierst du weniger, zahlst du halt auch weniger Steuern. Das ist ja im Prinzip auch okay.
Da muss ich an einem Punkt sein, in der ich sage, das kann ich mir überhaupt leisten, weniger zu konsumieren. Es gibt einen gewissen Grund, Teil, wo du sagst, den muss ich einfach konsumieren. Ich muss einfach essen. Ich brauche Kleidung. Es gibt einfach so ein paar Sachen, wo du sagst, die können wir zwar schlicht erhalten, aber wir können nicht ganz auf sie verzichten. Selbst der einfache Mönch, der in Armut lebt, kann nicht komplett konsumfrei leben. Das funktioniert eben nicht. Und das darüber hinaus ist ja schon mal eine Frage, dass sie sich leisten können.
Ja, aber das können ja wohl offensichtlich die meisten.
Das Sparen?
Nee, das Konsumieren darüber hinaus, über die Grundbedürfnisse hinaus. Wenn ich mir die Warenwelt heute so anschaue, was einem da so alles entgegengeschmissen wird, ich meine, das Allermeiste davon braucht ja keiner.
Das ist wohl wahr.
Es wird so viel Zeug produziert, wo man sich ernsthaft fragt. Also allein dieser ganze... Weihnachten ist mir so viel alles so klar geworden. Dieser ganze Tand, dieser ganze Quatsch, Geschenkschleifen. Das ist alles so glas, hübsch und schön und alles. Das kann man irgendwie wertschätzen und pipapo, aber nötig ist es nicht. Aber die Tatsache, dass es diese Produkte gibt, sagt einfach eine ganze Menge darüber aus, was wir uns auch schon leisten können. Weil sonst würde es ja auch gar keiner herstellen. Also, Herscharen von Menschen leben einfach nur davon, dass andere Leute sich zu einem Zwölftel des Jahres gerne Lichterketten in den Garten haben. Das kann man akzeptieren. So ist das halt. Ökologische Dimensionen dieser ganzen Produktvielfalt sei jetzt noch mal dahingestellt. Das ist noch mal ein ganz anderes Thema.
Das fasst ja nicht Stromsteuer ab.
Na gut, ich wollte das nun mal diskutiert haben. Ich will jetzt hier diese Grundeinkommendiskussion nicht wirklich so aufmachen, sondern vielleicht eher die Basis legen, auch um überhaupt zu verstehen, wie solche Steuersysteme zu machen. Weil jetzt hier die Diskussion aufzumachen mit wie bauen wir unser Steuersystem um. Ich glaube, da werden wir jetzt hier nicht wirklich vorherkommen. Aber bleiben wir noch mal kurz bei unserem Überblick und unserem halbwegs strukturierten Einsatz, uns diesem Thema zu widmen. Wir hatten jetzt den großen Teil Besitzsteuer. Jetzt sind wir bei Verkehrssteuer. Davon eben vor allem und im Wesentlichen die Umsatzsteuer, dem Volksmund auch Mehrwertsteuer genannt. Und über den Charakter des Mehrwerts dieser Produktionskette und der Notwendigkeit, darauf eine Steuer zu machen, kann man trefflich streiten, haben wir jetzt auch getan. Darüber hinaus gibt es noch andere Verkehrssteuer, wie du schon erwähnt hattest, Grunderwerbsteuer, also beim Verkauf von Gebäuden oder von Grund, also auch von Land sozusagen. Oder gibt es Grunderwerb? Wenn ich jetzt meinen Hektar verkaufe, dann fällt da Grunderwerbsteuer drauf ein.
Genau, und zivilrechtlich ist es so, ich verkaufe weniger das Gebäude obendrauf, sondern ich verkaufe den Boden, und da hängt das Gebäude mit dran.
Okay, ist aber ein Teil.
Auch wenn ich eine Eigentumswohnung verkaufe, auch dort fällt Grunderwerbsteuer an. Das ist auch eine Steuer, die im Gesamthaushalt wirklich eine überragende Rolle spielt.
Aber auf eine Eigentumswohnung zahlt ich keine Grundsteuer?
Grunderwerbsteuer.
Ich zahle Grundsteuer auf eine Eigentumswohnung?
Ja, das wird dann auch bei den Eigentumswohnungen...
Ach so, aber anteilig für den Grund, auf dem die steht?
Ja, das wird dann umgerechnet auf diese ganzen Eigentumswohnungen.
Also kommt jetzt nicht noch mehr Grund dazu, indem man halt einfach noch zehn Etagen draufbaut, das man auf einmal zehnmal so viel Grund hat?
Nein, du hättest einen höheren Ertragswert, dadurch würdest du die Grundsteuer zwar etwas anheben, aber es wird nicht mehr Fläche. Das ist eben gesagt nicht der Ansatz dort. Und die Grunderwerbsteuer, das ist schon, das ist im Gesamthaushalt im Vergleich zu so etwas wie Umsatzsteuer oder Einkommensteuer natürlich ein Spinz-Peanut. Aber es ist auch nicht so, dass es zu fadachlässig ist.
Aber wir hatten ja auch schon, bestimmte Steuern müssen auch irgendwie erhoben werden, einfach um eine Steuergerechtigkeit herzustellen. Dass wenn man sie einfach zu sehr weglassen würde, dass dann andere Steuern zu sehr an Einzelne leiden lassen würden, während andere mit ähnlichen Verdienstoptionen halt da nicht.
Es ist halt so das Potpourri, was es so kompliziert macht, was aber eben auch versucht, die verschiedenen Ecken und Enden halbwegs abzugreifen. Also erstens mal, dass man natürlich auch gleichzeitig überall reingreift, aber auch, dass ich versuche, die verschiedenen Wege dort abzufassen.
Aber warum sagt man nicht einfach, Umsatzsteuer bezieht sich jetzt auf jeden Verkauf? Auch auf die Versicherung, auch auf den Grunderwerb. Geht es jetzt nur darum, dass man andere Prozentsätze anschlagen will, das separat regeln will? Oder ist das irgendwie auch nochmal anders?
Also das hat einmal geschichtliche Hintergründe. Das hat sich einfach mal so entwickelt. Es gibt fiskalisch nicht zu verachtende Gründe dafür. Denn gerade was die Versicherungssteuer angeht und auch was die Grunderwerbsteuer angeht, erstens mal sind sie im Bund-Länder-Finanzausgleich anders gegliedert. Die Grunderwerbsteuer obliegt, wenn ich das noch so richtig in Erinnerung habe, den Ländern. Und im Vergleich dazu, die Umsatzsteuer wird ganz anders aufgeteilt. Also da fangen wir wieder bei den Gründerwerbsteuerern.
Das hatten wir ja im Prinzip schon mal. Das heißt, andere steuern teilweise auch deshalb, weil einfach der Verteilungsschlüssel ist.
Der Verteilungsschlüssel ist ein anderer. Und die Ausgaben für die Grunderwerbsteuer kann ich eben nicht als Vorsteuer ziehen unter für die Versicherungssteuer. Also auch ich als Unternehmer werde voll mit der Versicherungssteuer belastet. Für meine Berufshaftpflicht, die ich als Anwalt brauche oder für meine Hausrahr. Das ist keine Vorsteuer sozusagen. Die bleibt mir wirklich hängen als Ausgabe.
Kann man aber dann auch voll geltend machen als Ausgabe eben.
Als Betriebsausgabe.
Das heißt, wenn ich mich irgendwo versichere, dann verdient der Staat daran mit. Warum auch immer. Na gut.
Das ist dann so die, natürlich diese Rechtfertigungsdebatte. Da gibt es auch herrliche Forschung von einem Tippge.
Ich freue mich schon auf die Kommentare zu dieser Sendung. Aber ich wollte ja nur erklären. So, das heißt, jetzt haben wir diese Verkehrssteuer-Kategorie im Prinzip auch schon in den Deckel zugemacht. Ja, da sind wir zu Besitzsteuern, Verkehrssteuern und außerdem Verbrauchsteuern. Na, da freuen wir uns doch bestimmt alle.
Die Verbrauchsteuern sind zuvor das sogenannte Mineralölsteuer. Jeder, der Auto fährt, ist also fleißig mit dabei. Die Tabaksteuer und die Stromsteuer.
Wenn ich jetzt tanke, zahl ich aber auch Umsatzsteuer.
Ja, also das ist ja das, was immer wieder harsh kritisiert wird, von denen, die viel Auto fahren. Auf den Preis des Benzinens kommt die Mineralölsteuer drauf und dann auf das Gesamtpackage nochmal die Umsatzsteuer. Die Umsatzsteuer, die kann ich mir als Unternehmer eben wieder als Vorsteuer holen, die Mineralölsteuer nicht. Die ist definitiv weg.
Bei jedem Verkauf?
Die ist bei jedem Verkauf ein Benzin.
Das heißt, wenn ich irgendwie Benzin kaufe und Benzin wieder verkaufe, dann fällt jedes Mal bei jedem Verkauf einmal Mineralölsteuer drauf an?
Ich gebe zu, ich kenne das Mineralölsteuergesetz nicht in Detail, weil ich keine Mandanten habe, die der Refinery angehören. Aber vermute ich, ähnlich dürfte es sicher fallen, wie bei der Kaffee-Steuer, das weiß ich eben, weil ich da Mandanten habe. Bei der Kaffee-Steuer ist es auch so, wenn ich Kaffee, den ich das erste Mal in das Gebiet der Bundesrepublik einführe, dort muss ich Kaffee-Steuer zahlen, die auch einen festen Satz hat. Also da kommt dann darauf an, für einen Kilo, da gibt es so verschiedene Kaffeeklassen, löslicher Kaffee und normaler Boden-Kaffee und so was, muss ich Kaffee-Steuer abführen. Ich glaube, das ist bei, wenn ich das richtig erinnere, haben wir ein Kilo Kaffee, 2,13 Euro oder so was, also das ist nicht in Betracht festmachen, aber so in der Größenordnung reden wir da, muss ich Kaffee-Steuer abführen. Und für die weiteren Verkäufe, wenn es dann einmal im Gebiet der Bundesrepublik angekommen ist und einmal mit Kaffee-Steuer belastet wurde, dann war es das auch. Also das ist ein Großhändler, den ich da betreue, der den Kaffee weiterverkauft und der noch mal verkauft, der braucht sich nicht mehr drum gewöhnen. Ich vermute jetzt mal, ich muss wirklich mal nachgucken bei der Mineralöl-Steuer, dass es dort endlich geregelt sein wird, dass ich dort sage, wenn ich es einmal in den Verkehr bringe, dann muss ich das abführen. Das macht diese Steuer halt auch sehr bequem bei der Erhebung. Diejenigen, die das einführen oder herstellen, also wenn ich hier eine Kaffee-Plantage hätte, hätte ich dasselbe Problem, die das einmal in den Verkehr bringen, die sind eben dran. Das ist ein überschaubacher Bereich.
Jetzt stellt sich erstmal wieder das Warum. Warum muss ich dafür, dass ich Kaffee ins Land hole, dem Staat Geld geben?
Weil das böse ist?
Ist das eine Bestrafung?
Also bei Kaffee kann es sich eigentlich nur um eine noch übriggebliebene Luxussteuer handeln. Also es gab geschichtlich sogenannte Luxussteuer. Da hatten wir eben auch mal die Leuchtmittelsteuer, die haben wir dann irgendwann auch mal abgeschafft.
Eine Leuchtmittelsteuer?
Ja, bis 1993 wurden Glühbirnen extra besteuert. Also da gab es das auch. Und ich hatte bei mir noch so ein Zettel, die Zündwarensteuer, die hatten wir auch bis 1981. Also Streichhölzer, Feuerzeuge, Feuersteine, die wurden auch extra besteuert. Das sind alte Luxussteuer. Ich vermute mal, dass die Kaffee-Steuer auch so eine übriggebliebene ist.
Weil ich mir mein Feuer nicht mehr durch das Reiben von Hölzchen selber mache oder was?
Ja, weil wer sich das leisten kann, der ist halt besonders.
Ah, da sind wieder diese Snops mit ihren Feuerzeugen.
Genau, ja.
Während wir normaler Zöge immer noch so mit unseren Zündsteinchen irgendwie rauflaufen.
Und dann noch umschlagen, ja.
Luxussteuer, interessant.
Ja, und bei diesen Luxussteuern, also...
Ja, aber was steckt da drin? Also was... Das ist Luxus, auch so dieses... Sind wir da wieder bei diesem... Du hast viel, du kannst dir ein gutes Leben leisten. Dafür hast du einfach dem... Die Allgemeinheit nochmal extra was abzuführen, dafür, dass du da rumposerst, sozusagen.
Ja, du nimmst dir etwas, was eigentlich keiner wirklich braucht. Wer Kaffee trinkt, das ist Luxus. Muss man eben nur mal 100 Jahre zurückdenken, da war es halt wirklich nur Luxus. Und wie das halt mit Steuern so ist, wenn Steuern einmal da sind.
Dann gehen sie ja so schnell nicht wieder weg. Weil sie müssen ja aber auch ursprünglich erstmal durchgesetzt worden sein. Ich meine, man hätte ja nun alles Mögliche in dieses Land tragen können. Und davon ausgehen, dass wenn ich mir schon die Mühe mache, das jetzt hierher zu bringen und dann noch jemanden zu verkaufen, dass ja dann sehr wohl schon an Umsatzsteuern, anderen Steuern letztlich da was verdient wird. Warum soll jetzt die Kaffeebohne als konkrete Natur verbrauchen? Ich meine, gibt es auch eine Reissteuer? Kartoffelsteuer?
Bambussteuer? Ich glaube, wir hatten mal ganz früher die Salzsteuer noch. Auch noch so ein Luxusgegenstand, aber das ist auch schon lange her. Das ist ja kaum nachzuvollziehen, gerade beim Kaffee, weil es heute kein wirkliches Luxusgut mehr ist. Und warum man sich dann bei so einer Luxussteuer ausgerechnet diese und nicht andere Sachen nimmt, das sind politische Entscheidungen.
Aber auf den Rolls-Royce fällt jetzt in dem Sinne keine Luxussteuer an?
Nein, also fällt nicht. Pelzsteuer gibt es ja auch nicht.
Gibt es den Begriff Luxussteuer überhaupt noch?
Na, es gibt diesen Begriff...
In der Forschung sozusagen.
Ja, also man klassifiziert damit eben bestimmt. In der Wissenschaft sozusagen. Ja, also rechtswissenschaftlich benutzt man diesen Begriff schon, um Steuern...
Aber du hast keine Kategorie in deinem Steuerhandbuch irgendwie, wo Luxussteuer drin steht.
Nein, weil man versucht eigentlich nur, die Rechtfertigung für diese Steuer damit zu erklären, dass man sagt, okay, das sind Warensteuer oder Leuchtmittelsteuer. Das ist eben durch nichts anderes zu erklären als, als die Leuchtmittel mal aufkamen, waren es eben, wie viel Glühbirnen sich jemand leisten konnte, war ein Zeichen für Luxus, dass er eben keine Kerzen rumstehen hatte, sondern wirklich...
Also das ist eigentlich für dich diese Argumentation mit, wir kriegen langsam das Gefühl, du hast mehr Geld als......
dir zusteht so....
als dir zusteht so. Du kannst ja wohl noch mehr abgeben.
Und auch das ist nichts Neues. Also Leuchtmittelsteuer, das haben wir zwar abgeschafft, aber im Mittelalter wurden auch Kerzen nach diesem Prinzip gesteuert. Kerzen. Jemand, der sich besonders viele Kerzen leisten kann, der muss es echt haben. Kerzen waren teuer. Das war ein Luxusgut. Wer sich es leisten kann, seinen Raum abends lichterhell zu machen, der soll auch ordentlich verzahlen. Also das ist Luxus, den man so versucht wegzunehmen.
Kaffee steuern. Dann gibt es wahrscheinlich auch eine Tee-Steuer.
Die gibt es nicht, nee.
Nein?
Nein, Tee-Steuer nicht.
Ach, Tee ist kein Luxus.
Ja, man merkt es schon. Es ist Beliebigkeit. Man könnte auch bei vielen anderen Sachen zugreifen, die vielleicht einem jetzt auch viel eher nach Luxus aussehen, als Kaffee oder Tee. Also, woran diese Beliebigkeit auch zu merken ist, es gibt auch eine sogenannte Schaumweinsteuer. Unter der Schaumweinsteuer fällt Sekt und Champagner. Nicht darunter fällt Prosecco.
Weil der schäumt nicht genug.
Warum auch immer fällt das eben nicht unter die Klassifikation. Ja, das ist nicht Schaumwein, sondern das Prosecco ist Wein. Das finde ich schon aber witzig, dass ich bei den Jubis irgendwann mal der Prosecco durchgesetzt hab, war eine galante Möglichkeit, Schaumweinsteuer einzusparen. Also ich weiß nicht, ob es so wirklich einen Zusammenhang gab. Und ich hab die Höhe der Schaumweinsteuer nicht im Kopf, aber es ist gar nicht so wenig. Die Schaumweinsteuer auf einen Liter Sekt, da ist schon erstaunlich, wie wenig der angeboten wird im Regal. Pro Seco ist im Verhältnis gesehen dazu deutlich billiger, weil diese blöde Schaumweinsteuer nicht anfällt. Da ist wirklich nur Umsatzsteuer drauf.
Wie viel macht das?
Ich hab die Zahl leider nicht mehr im Kopf.
Ich guck grad mal bei Pro Seco nach, was das eigentlich ist. Das ist eine bestimmte Rebsorte. Man macht daraus aber auch Schaumweine.
Ja, aber es ist eben steuerlich kein Schaumwein. Da bin ich zu wenig.
Okay, gut, ich erwarte nicht, dass du das jetzt alles beantworten kannst. Ich versuch das nur gerade so mal nachzuvollziehen. Okay, gut, das macht alles keinen Sinn. Das deckt meine Erwartungshaltung. Aber was gibt es denn noch für nennenswerte Verbrauchsteuer? Tabaksteuer haben wir ja schon erwähnt. Die wird aber nicht nur beim Import gezahlt, oder? Wie der Kaffee?
Da hab ich ja auch dieses Banderolensystem. Da musste der Hersteller die Tabaksteuer einmal abführen.
Ach so, und dafür, dass man die abgeführt hat, dafür kommt dann die Banderole auf die Packung. Die Banderolen werden so richtig vom Staat dahingetragen.
Das ist das Steuerstempelzeichen. Damit weiß ich, das Ding ist besteuert. Um sie eben auch von den Schwarzzigaretten.
Interessant, gibt es das eigentlich noch bei irgendwas anderem?
Das sollte bei der Banderolen draufgeklebt werden.
Das ist mir...
Also Kaffee hat es beispielsweise nicht.
Ja, genau. Obwohl das ja auch nur so eine Einmalzahlung ist.
Wüsste ich jetzt aus dem Stegreif auch nicht, wo ich noch so steuerbare Banderolen verwende.
Macht man auch so, weil das immer schon so war? Oder ist es wirklich nötig? Na gut, ich meine, wenn man so die Polenzigaretten mal in die Hand kriegt, die haben halt auch keine. Also zumindest daran erinnern.
Ja, du kriegst damit die Schwarzmarkt-Zigaretten halt sehr schön separiert. Also wenn einer Zigaretten verkauft, die halt keine Banderolen, dann ist halt der Fall geklärt. Dann brauchen wir nicht weiter drüber philosophieren.
Aber es gibt bestimmt auch nachgemachte Banderolen, oder nicht?
Gut, es ist nicht dein Unfällchen. Ich war zwar in der Ausbildung auch mal eine kurze Zeit bei der Staatsanwaltschaft Steuerstrafrecht. Und da fällt ja eben auch dieser Zigaretten-Schmuggel rein. Aber weil ich in Frankfurt-Oder war und dort tritt das ja dann doch häufiger auf. Aber nachgemachte Banderolen, das ist mir da auch nicht so richtig unterkommen. Vielleicht lohnt sich das einfach nicht. Also das, wenn man schon bescheißt, dann auch gleich richtig.
Welche Verbrauchsteuern sind denn so die großen Einnehmer? Also Mineralolsteuer und Tabaksteuer spielt sicherlich eine große Rolle. Kaffee-Steuer, keine Ahnung?
Das ist untergeordnet. Noch eine große Rolle die Brandweinsteuer. Wer also hartes liebt, der ist auch mit dabei. Und dann auch so eine Mischung aus Einnahmen und Lenkungsteuer ist die Stromsteuer. Also wie bei der Tabaksteuer, Stromsteuer. Weil ich damit ja auch einen Lenkungseffekt haben will. Ich will ja, dass die Leute weniger Strom verbrauchen. Und der Staat hat natürlich, steht ja auch so zwischen Baum und Borken, weil bei der letzten Tabaksteuer-Erhöhung ist es tatsächlich das erste Mal aufgetreten, dass sie nicht zu wirklich mehr Einnahmen geführt hat. Entweder haben die Leute dann tatsächlich weniger gerocht oder mehr schwarze Koffee gehabt, wie auch immer. Dort hat sich das mal ins Gegenteil umgeschlagen. Und bei der Stromsteuer ist es eigentlich auch so.
War dann der Staat dann enttäuscht?
Vermutlich ja.
Eigentlich müsste er ja jubilieren.
Ja, aber er hat die Erhöhung nicht gemacht, damit die Leute weniger rauchen, sondern damit er mehr Geld kriegt. Das ist bei den Lenkungsteuern das Schwierige. Du willst einen Lenkungseffekt haben, aber irgendwie willst du auch die Einnahmen haben. Eigentlich wärst du dem Staat recht, wenn die Leute alle richtig ihre Lichter anmachen und vor allen Dingen ihre PCs laufen lassen. Die fressen ja so richtig Strom. Andererseits will man sich auch Grün geben, ohne der jetzt auf einzelne Parteien einzubringen. Man will sich Grün geben und will auch, dass die Leute möglichst wenig Strom verbrauchen.
Das ist jetzt eigentlich eine neue Komponente der letzten 20 Jahre. Die ganze ökologische Diskussion und auch überhaupt so Ressourcenschonung, das sind ja einfach so Begriffe, die man vor 20 Jahren noch nicht so gehabt hat. Da hat man es halt einfach aus Mutti Erde rausgeholt, wie es so kam. Und jetzt merkt man, dass damit ja auch letzten Endes wiederum gesellschaftliche Kosten verbunden sind. Wir jetzt gar nicht mit globaler Erwärmung anfangen, aber so Müll zum Beispiel ist ja ein echtes Thema. Müllsteuer, gibt es sowas eigentlich? Das fände ich ja mal ganz angemessen. Dass man auf etwas, was einfach viel Müll enthält, im Sinne von Verpackungen und so weiter, oder schlechter Entsorgbarkeit, also es gibt ja für Elektronik Entsorgungsabgaben oder sowas.
Das gibt es, aber das ist keine Steuer. Also die Abgaben, die ich dort zahlen muss, die fließen nicht ins allgemeine Säcke, sondern diese Elektroschrott, dort ist das System so, dass ich Rückstellungen bilden muss, dafür teilweise Bürgschaft machen muss, also ein relativ kompliziertes Verfahren, um dann mal einen Anteil von Müll auch wirklich dort die Entsorgungskosten zu tragen. Da kriege ich wirklich bildlich jedenfalls einen Container hingestellt und dann wird mir gesagt, du hast jetzt in den letzten zehn Jahren ungefähr einen Container vollgemacht, also einen Container mit allem Möglichen, stellen wir die jetzt mal hin und kümmer dich mal darum, dass der jetzt ordentlich wegkommt. Und dann fahre ich den persönlich irgendwo hin.
Gut, aber jetzt bei der Energie ist es natürlich definitiv so. Man weiß, wie viel Energie erzeugen ist keine gute Idee und es wird immer besser, wenn man weniger macht. Das heißt, darüber kann so eine Verbrauchsteuer nun wirklich ja auch einen, ja einen, hat es meiner Meinung nach auch einen regulierenden Effekt. Wenn Strom teuer ist, dann merkt man, stellen die Leute sich um, entweder indem sie einfach weniger, was weiß ich, Geräte zum Einsatz bringen und vielleicht mal häufiger irgendwas ausschalten, das vielleicht noch weniger, aber vor allem in der Industrie, in der Produktion und so weiter, gerade jetzt hier Internet und so, da ist ja nun Strom wirklich Nummer eins Thema.
Soviel gesagt, bei Rechenzentren vor 10 Jahren hat auch noch keiner ernst genommen, über den Stromverspruch gesprochen.
Und mittlerweile ist es ein richtiges Verkaufsargument für einen Server, wenn er einfach nur die Hälfte frisst.
Ja, teilweise werden die Dinger neu gekauft, gerade weil man sagt, das spart so viel Strom.
Das finanziert sich allein schon deswegen.
Das ist ja schon ein interessanter Punkt. Unabhängig davon, dass ich natürlich auch damit wieder ein bisschen Wirtschaft ankurbel, weil die Leute ja alle neue Geräte kaufen. Viel früher, als es sonst getan hätte.
Also die Alwissene Müllhalle, also ich bezeichne ja die GP als Alwissene Müllhalle, andere Leute halten Google für die Alwissene Müllhalle. Aber da kommt nicht so viel Wissen raus, finde ich. Ja genau, spricht auch davon, dass im Wesentlichen diese Verbrauchsteuerungen immer dann kommen, dann kamen als irgendwas als Luxusgüt gut galt. Ja, das heißt es gibt Steuern für Erdgas, es gibt für Strom und so weiter. Mittlerweile gibt es ja sogar eine Alkoholpop-Steuer.
Stimmt, das wurde dann auch mal eingeführt. Auch das Lenkungsteuer, das sind wir eben auch bei den wirklich Lenken. Man kann sich schon fragen, macht das Sinn, oder führt es eben dann nicht am Ende der Strecke nur zu Umgehungseffekten? Ich maube da nicht mehr die Fenster zu, sondern ich sauf auf einmal auf was anderes. Fenstersteuerung, okay dann machen wir wieder ein paar Fenster zu oder so.
Okay, ich finde halt alle die Salzsteuer, die es wieder aufgegeben worden ist. Es gab auch eine Tee-Steuer, die es wieder aufgegeben war. Aber Kaffee ist immer noch Luxus genug.
War da nicht mit der Boston Tea Party auch was mit Tee-Besteuerung, da Amerika hatten die das Thema nicht auch mal?
Da erwischte ich einen linken Füßen, die ich zu bieten habe. Was ist die Boston Tea Party?
War das nicht irgendwie, dass sie dann mal den ganzen Tee reingeschmissen haben, weil die Briten dort irgendwelche Abgaben haben wollten, als sie Tee nach Amerika eingeführt haben? So ganz dunkle Erinnerungen.
Ich schlage das gerade mal nach. Ich weiß davon gar nichts. Die Boston Tea Party bezahlt sich für ein Akt des Widerstandes gegen die britische Kolonialpolitik. Die haben irgendwie Tee ins Hafenbecken geschmissen.
Aber sollten die nicht auch gezwungen werden, Abgaben zu zahlen?
Hat irgendwas mit Steuer und Zoll zu tun. Ist mir zu lang, um das hier irgendwie. Gibt einen Teeakt und so weiter. Wissen wir nicht. Müssen wir selber nachgucken. Gibt hier nicht alle Informationen einfach so? Hier muss ein bisschen mitgedacht und mitgearbeitet werden. Ja, trotzdem. Die Sache erklärt sich in zunehmendem Maße. Zoll, ist das eigentlich auch ein Teil des Ganzen?
Das ist ein Teil des Ganzen. Das ist ein besonderer Teil, der wirklich ausgeklammert ist. Also der Zoll-Codex, also das, was wir wirklich als Zolleinnahmen haben, läuft nebenher. Und da geht es dann wirklich um die Einfuhr von bestimmten Waren.
Aber im weiteren Sinne geht es auch um die Erhaltung der Effizienz des eigenen Steuersystems.
Auch, ja.
Also gerade was Verbrauchsteuern und so weiter betrifft.
Zoll ist halt auch so eine uralte Geschichte. Zoll, also Zöllner, das ist ja auch biblisch. Zöllner sind biblisch? Und hatten damals einen sehr schlechten Ruf.
Was meinst du damit, die gibt es erst seit der Bibel?
Nein, ich meine, die gab es eben damals schon. Die hatten damals schon einen sehr schlechten Ruf. Ich will auch nicht darüber werten, ob der Ruf heute besser oder schlechter ist.
Was ist denn so? Wie nimmst du denn das so wahr bei deiner Tätigkeit? Wir haben jetzt schon viel über Gerechtigkeit und so weiter gesprochen. Und was irgendwie funktioniert und was nicht funktioniert. Ist es so, dass ihr das eigentlich selber alles einleuchtet und dass du dir immer wunderst, warum das jetzt keiner versteht? Oder nimmst du das ganze System irgendwie so als durcheinander wahr?
Nein, also das tue ich nicht. Es gibt schon wirklich Punkte, wo ich mir denke, das tut nicht so richtig not oder wo ich auch sehe, dass wir Gerechtigkeitsdefizite haben oder eben sowas wie Solidarität. Ich sage mir, das kann man doch wirklich mal vereinfachen, ohne dass es jetzt jemandem wehtut und wo ich auch nicht so richtig nachvollziehen kann, warum. Und da sieht man schon, man könnte einiges machen, aber man sagt, ein großes Problem ist eben viel in dem Bereich, kriege ich halt in der Bildzeitungsunterschrift Überschrift nicht so richtig reingepackt, das kriege ich nicht verkauft. Und da passiert schon auch vieles im Hintergrund, was keiner so richtig mitkriegt, was einem eigentlich schade ist, dass es keiner mitkriegt, sowohl Gutes als auch Schlechtes. Es ist nicht so, dass ich da alles mitnachvollziehen kann oder mittrage, aber da stehe ich auch nur als Anwender des Ganzen da.
Ja, ich denke da haben wir jetzt das Thema auch ganz gut abgefeuert. Wir hatten ja schon, hat der Eingang schon erwähnt, du hast diesen Vortrag gehalten, die Digitalisierung des Steuerbetriebs und so. Das Fass machen wir jetzt hier irgendwie nicht mehr auf, weil das ist ein weitergehendes Ding.
Sonst haben wir die nächsten zwei Stunden.
Ich meine, könnte man durchaus nochmal überlegen, das hier auch im CRE auch nochmal anzugehen. Finde ich auf jeden Fall spannend. Ich wollte bloß überhaupt erstmal so ein bisschen die Grundlage legen, dass es jetzt sicherlich erfolgt. Wer das jetzt sozusagen unmittelbar interessiert, der kann sich da einen Vortrag anschauen. Aber vielleicht machen wir das, wenn wir dann, glaube ich, eine Reaktion in den Kommentaren sehen, ob es sozusagen die Leute, die jetzt den Vortrag gesehen haben, das ganz gerne auch nochmal aufgeklambüsert bekommen wollen. Ich stelle ja immer wieder fest, dass man so im Dialogischen auch die Dinge dann manchmal doch noch ein bisschen fester festnageln kann, als das in so einem Vortrag einem immer so gelingt, auch weil das immer so dicht ist. Ja, da können wir dann die Vorteile des Podcastings voll ausspielen. Ansonsten hoffe ich, dass wir jetzt hier einen ganz brauchbaren Überblick zumindest über das deutsche Steuerkonzept gemacht haben. Ich meine, da war jetzt auch so viel Allgemeines drin. Ich denke mal, da wird sich auch in anderen Ländern eine ganze Menge davon wiederfinden.
Ja, ohne Zweifel.
Und naja, vielleicht gibt es sich auch irgendwann mal die Möglichkeit, diese ganze europäische Dimension nochmal näher zu beleuchten. Europa müsste ja auch irgendwann nochmal so ein Thema sein, nicht nur was jetzt so Steuer betrifft, sondern generell eigentlich so diese ganze Rechtskonstellation in der EU.
Also in der Umsatzsteuer ist es schon ein gewaltiges Thema. Das Umsatzsteuerrecht, das wir haben, ist maßgeblich durch die europäische Union beeinflusst.
Das ist diese Mehrwertsteuer-Richtlinie, die du angemessen hast.
Ja, es gibt mehrere von und Systemrichtlinien, weißte was.
Das heißt, Deutschland ist sozusagen auch gar nicht mehr so frei in der Art und Weise, wie Steuergesetz überhaupt noch gestaltet oder gar reformiert werden kann?
Jedenfalls was die Umsatzsteuerung geht? Nein. Also da sind sie ziemlich festgenagelt. Bei den anderen Steuern besteht noch eine erhebliche Freiheit. Aber auch da europäisches Recht ist immer im Hinterkopf zu behalten. Also es ist nicht so, dass man dann zwischendurch frei von ist.
Und so eine richtige Reform? Was weiß ich hier, Bierdeckel, Zanzette?
Find ich herrlich, ja. Also das zumindest, ich hab keine Angst in meinem Berufsstand, weil das ist in anderen Ländern mitnichten so. Also auch wenn überhaupt das deutsche Steuerrecht so irre kompliziert ist, ist es wahrlich nicht so, dass das irgendwie einfach ist. Aber es ist auch nicht so, dass das in anderen Ländern alles irgendwie auf dem Bierdeckel passiert.
Aber ich hab gehört, stimmt das eigentlich, oder ist das nur so eine Urban Legend, dass irgendwie, jetzt muss ich ein bisschen raten, so was wie 70% aller geschriebenen Bücher und sonstigen festgehaltenen Informationen zum Thema Steuerrecht sich auf das deutsche Steuerrecht beziehen.
Und der Nachtrag ist immer, die restlichen 30% schaffen wir auch noch. Also die Zahl kenn ich auf 90%.
Ja, keine Ahnung, ob die überhaupt auf irgendwas anderem fußt als an der Mutmaßung. Aber kann das so sein?
Also in denen Dimension halt es für hoffnungslos überdreht. Also das Steuerrecht ist schon ein sehr eigenes, sehr komplexes Thema. Das kann man nicht abstreiten. Es ist aber eben nicht so, dass es überall anders irgendwie so richtig einfacher wäre. Also ich hab mich mal mit der amerikanischen Erbschaftssteuer mal näher befassen müssen und dachte mir dann so, warum haben die nicht unsere? Das ist doch irgendwie viel einfacher. Also das ist nicht unser größtes Schwerpunkt, auch Erbschaftssteuer. Also da haben wir nicht unsere größten Probleme, was Komplexität angeht. Aber da hab ich ja nämlich die Feststellung gemacht, es gibt andere Länder, wo es auch jedenfalls ein Teilbereich mal schlimmer sein kann. Nichtsdestotrotz, wir könnten viel vereinfachern und das wäre auch dringend nötig. Und das ohne, dass ich jetzt irgendwie Sorgen hätte, ich hätte morgen nichts mehr zu tun, das könnte jeder selbst machen. Also jedenfalls im unternehmerischen Bereich wird das immer so bleiben und das zeigen uns auch andere Länder. Weil die Probleme, die dahinter stecken, sind halt komplexe Vorgänge und die wird man nie so schlicht kriegen.
Aber trotzdem ist doch eine Vereinheitlichung oder Vereinfachung der Vorgänge letzten Endes auch in deinem Sinne. Oder selbst wenn es das nicht wäre, wäre das ja durchaus wünschenswert. Es ist ja nicht so, dass das Steuersystem als solches als besonders durchschaubar und leicht verständlich gilt.
Nein, im Gegenteil. Also der Punkt, in dem auch diejenigen, die es wirklich täglich anwenden, noch durchsehen, ist schon lange vorbei. Also man könnte vieles vereinfachen, ohne dass man mal, dass man wirklich sagt, man kann jetzt auf den Steuerberater oder auf den Rechtsanwalt verzichten. Also da könnten wir noch ganze Dimensionen runter beamen und würden immer noch auf einem Niveau bleiben und sagen, der Laie wird nicht durchsehen.
Na gut, aber um diese Vereinfachungen zu erzielen, was würdest du vorschlagen, welchen Pfad man dort im Wesentlichen beschreiten muss? Also vielleicht mehr im politischen Prozess allgemein, als was die einzelnen Regelungen selber betrifft?
Ich glaube, es sind die einzelnen Regelungen, wo die Schwierigkeiten treffen, wo die Schwierigkeiten auftreten. Es sind nicht die großen Pfade.
Was ich meine, ist, welchen politischen Ansatz müsste man wählen? Also jetzt mal so für die Politiker von morgen und andere Hobbypolitiker gesprochen. Also wenn man jetzt wirklich sich auf diesen Pfad begeben will, ohne gleich das komplette Studium des Steuerrechts aufzunehmen, muss ja dann auch die Möglichkeit geben, für einen Politiker dort zu walten, ohne sich komplett nur noch in dieses Thema zu gießen.
Ich glaube, da wird es eben schwierig, weil ich mir immer angucken muss, wenn ich an der einen Stellschraube was drehe, wo wirkt sich das denn sonst noch überall aus?
Wie wäre es denn mit einer Simulation? Gibt es denn das?
Sowas gibt es tatsächlich. Also ich habe mal so einen Vortrag erlebt, wo jemand vom Bundesfinanzministerium mit dabei saß, die Veränderungen im Umsatzsteuerrecht tatsächlich Rollen-Strategiespiele wie auch immer gemacht haben, die also da in verschiedenen Räumen versucht haben, Wirtschaft nachzuspielen, um zu sehen bei einem Gesetz, aber das wird leider viel zu wenig gemacht. Aber dort hat man es mal gemacht, wo man versucht hat, mit einem Systemwechsel, den man vorhatte, im Vorfeld rauszukriegen, wo sind die Schwachstellen, wo könnte es unter Umständen umgangen werden. Also in Einzelfällen gibt es das tatsächlich. Das wäre schön, wenn man das viel mehr machen würde, um auch bei anderen Gesetzen viel früher Fehler zu entdecken. Mal so ein Betatest im kleinen Rahmen.
Immerhin geht es ja um Geld und man kann ja dann immerhin das anzahlen. Ich meine, die politische Wirkung oder die gesellschaftliche Wirkung, die etwas hat, das ist ja jetzt nochmal eine ganz andere Geschichte. Gerade wenn man jetzt so lenkt und einwirken will. Was sagt die Leute, sollen weniger rauchen, was auch immer. Das ist das eine. Aber wenn es sozusagen gerade um diesen eigentlichen Streitpunkt der Ungerechtigkeit, wenn ihr jetzt hier diese Stellschraube ändert, dann fallen euch irgendwie 50% der Bauern hinten über. Das sind ja dann in der politischen Diskussion, bis es soweit ist, erst mal Behauptungen. Ich würde auch den Lobbyisten immer unterstellen wollen, dass sie natürlich immer mal bei Default erst mal mauern, weil sie selber die Auswirkungen gar nicht so sehr unterblicken und unter Umständen vielleicht sogar eigene Vorteile am Ende nicht sehen. Wenn man halt mehr dazu hingehen würde, dieses ganze System auch in einer Permanentsimulation zu unterhalten, ich meine, es ist ja nicht so, dass die Finanzamt keine Daten hätte darüber, welche Steuern dann tatsächlich anfallen.
Es ist voll vorkommend, dass da ein paar Daten gesammelt werden.
Genau, dann müsste sich ja da im Prinzip auch ganz gut feststellen lassen, ja, wenn wir jetzt irgendwie das ändern, wo fallen denn dann die ganzen Domino-Steinchen um?
Dann müssten wir mal die Diskussion, die du ja schon mehrfach angesprochen hast, mal die Frage stellen, was ist dort gerecht? Also, welche Rechtfertigung haben wir für Steuern? Und was ist daran gerecht? Wie kriegen wir es gerechter? Uns dort immer wieder auch mal vor Augen halten müssten, wie sieht das verfassungsrechtlich aus? Das Thema Vermögensteuer, wo ich sage, nur einfach mal zu sagen, ich will die einen führen, ist eben nicht. Das ist eben nicht so einfach. Und müsste man dann mal überlegen, ob auch gerade Ideologie befreit, also von irgendwelchen politischen Diskussionen weg. Wie kriegen wir das denn technisch mal sauber umgesetzt? Und ich bin überzeugt davon, das scheidet schlichtweg da dran. Das ist ein Komplex, der ist schwierig, der würde einen langen Diskussionsprozess voraussetzen und einen Diskussionsprozess, den du eben schlecht in ein paar wenige Überschriften vermitteln kannst. Weil es wird Wirklichkeit abgebildet. Also Steuerrecht, das finde ich macht es ja auch spannend, Steuerrecht bildet tatsächlich echte Wirtschaft ab. Und Wirtschaft ist komplex. Und das kriegst du nicht in einer Zeile untergebracht.
Naja, vielleicht ist es aber die Gelegenheit. Ich will jetzt nicht zu sehr in technische Lösungen verrennen. Aber was weiß ich, so eine Open-Source-Simulation an der Stelle würde Open-Source wirklich sehr sinnvoll sein, wenn man sozusagen nachvollziehen kann, welche Regeln dort angewendet werden. Und jeder könnte sie sozusagen selber nachsimulieren. Das würde ja sozusagen allen ein Werkzeug in die Hand geben.
Das wäre sehr spannend. Und ich fände, das wäre auch mal überzeugend. Es gibt im Deutschen Bundestag nur eine einzige Partei, die tatsächlich eine Steuerreform so weit durchkonstizipiert hat, dass sie einen Gesetzentwurf in der Schublade legen hat. Bei allen anderen... Ohne jetzt sagen, sie wollen das, ob gut oder schlecht. Sie haben es so weit gebracht, dass man sagen muss, die könnten morgen ein Gesetz umsetzen. Ich hatte mich im Rahmen von der Seminararbeit damit mal näher beschäftigt mit dem Thema Steuergerechtigkeit. Es war erschreckend, dass bei allen anderen Parteien, wo du eigentlich außer ein paar Stichworten nichts findest, keiner hat sich hingesetzt und hat mal wirklich gesagt, wenn wir es machen wollten, wie wir durften, wie wir könnten, dann sähe es genauso aus. Hier sind die einzelnen Normen. Und die könnte man ja auch wirklich mal durchsimulieren. Und das, finde ich, hat schon was Überzeugendes. Ob man jetzt auf diesen einen Entwurf, den gut findet, selber dahingestellt, aber das überhaupt, wie man sagt, hier, wir zeigen euch, wie es wirklich aussehen könnte, das finde ich ist schon mal ein Stück Leistung. Und da könnte man so eine Simulation durchführen. Und es gibt ja im Netzumfeld auch eine Partei, die sich gerne mit technischen Lösungen widelt. Genau. Da ist das Thema Steuerrecht noch gar nicht angekommen so richtig. Aber das wäre ja mal interessant, wenn wir sagen, okay, wir führen mal was ein und wir zeigen euch, vielleicht indem auch ein paar sich bereit erklären, ihre Daten anonymisiert mal einzuspeisen, ihre Buchhaltung, die sie sowieso machen müssen. Und wir probieren mal aus, wie es so ist. Wir machen mal ein Online-Rollenspiel. In dem wir auch mal so ein bisschen kaufen und verkaufen gehen und leben da mal so ein bisschen und gucken, wie sich das steuerlich auswirkt. Wir kriegen nur unseren Quatsch eigentlich finanziert. Das ist so, hm.
Steuersim City.
Steuersim City, ja.
Ja Kai, mit den Wünschen und Vorstellungen können wir uns ja jetzt hier verabschieden. Vielen Dank für die Ausführung.
Ich danke dir vielmals, ja.
Rund um die Steuern. Mal gucken, ob wir hier nochmal einen Teil 2 machen mit dem ganzen Digitalkram. Das hängt alles von euch ab. Mein Themenbündel für die nächsten Tage und Wochen ist hier auf jeden Fall prächtig gefüllt. Es geht nicht mit Steuern weiter. Also ich kann schon mal verraten.
Schade eigentlich.
Aber naja, Technik, Kultur, Gesellschaft, das ist die Tagline hier im Programm. Und da passt das auf jeden Fall auch wunderbar rein. Ja, in diesem Sinne sage ich Tschüss und bis bald hier wieder bei Chaosradio Express.